This is Jocko podcast number 72 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening,
sir.
Casualties are inbound.
One of the mits has been hit hard and we have casualties headed to Fallujah
surgical.
My head snapped up from my work.
I quickly strapped on my nine millimeter headed off to Fallujah surgical,
the level two trauma and surgical facility on Camp Fallujah servicing the
casualties and medical needs of the eastern portion of Alan Bar province in
Iraq.
I made a habit of going to the operating rooms to see and encourage the wounded
whenever I was in the command post of two expedition to Marine Expeditionary
Force meth forward at Fallujah.
My aid,
Ben and I made our way through the maze of buildings and walls of the camp.
Something told me to hurry.
I quicken my pace then began to run.
I hadn't done this before and I'm sure my aid was wondering what was up.
As we rounded the corner of the hospital,
I could see the up armored Humvees or the Mitt team and the marines themselves
standing near the entrance.
They had their hands on their hips and their heads were down.
This is bad.
I thought one of the Marines was lifting a set of body armor from the floor of a
Hum v and it was covered with and dripping blood.
Yeah.
I quickly cleared my weapon at the clearing barrel barrel and stepped into the
facility.
The medical personnel had become accustomed to my presence on these occasions
and quickly brief me on the situation.
Several wounded one very seriously and the survivors were down the corridor in
an office.
I hustled down to the office and quickly got a situation report from the team
leader and others of whom was wounded and awaiting treatment.
Yeah.
It had been a bad ambush and the marines had fought for their lives alongside
the Iraqi troops.
They were advising then looking up at me with an anguish you can only find in
combat.
The team leader said to me in a hush tone,
we think Travis is dead.
I didn't immediately connect the name,
but I knew I needed to get down the corridor right away to the ors where the
incredible surgical teams were working frantically.
On the wounded.
As I stepped into the first or the surgical team was just finishing their work.
One of the nurses was crying openly.
They'd been unable
to save this marine and he had just died.
Seconds before I stepped into the or.
As I walked to the end of the Gurney,
I was stunned to see Travis Mannion,
the wonderful youngster I'd known as one of my midshipman's.
While I was commandant at the Naval Academy,
I had known his family,
his dad,
Tom,
a marine colonel himself and his mom,
Janet,
a stalwart of the family.
Travis had selected the core from Annapolis and though I had not seen him during
this first,
this tour in Fallujah,
I'd heard repeatedly of his courage and bravery as an advisor,
one by one.
The doctors and nurses left the Oh are leaving me alone with Travis.
I don't think I had ever prayed so hard for anyone or anything in my life as I
did while alone with him,
and that empty o r
is lost was very personal to me.
Three years later while I was deputy commander at Centcom and headed ultimately
to command the US forces in Afghanistan.
I learned of an incident the previous night that had taken the lives of some of
our magnificent special operators,
seals from seal team three
they'd been operating in the Zabul province,
south of the Hindu Kush and Afghanistan,
and a generally made the lives of the Taliban miserable the entire time they had
served there.
One of the finest young leaders in this seal team,
Brendan looney looked and lived every aspect of the ethos of being a seal this
now legendary Strada of American special ops community.
That night we lost Brendan Looney
as with Travis.
Brendan's death was not simply a loss to their respective units and missions.
Losing them was a terrible blow to America,
which would now never benefit from the extraordinary qualities of these two men.
The irony of their relationship and their seemingly unrelated deaths was nearly
as tragic.
Yeah.
They'd be been roommates at the United States Naval Academy growing up together
at this most hallowed institution of on of our naval service.
They had faced the challenges of navy and they had emerged committed in ways for
you can understand without experiencing the powerful formative forces of
Annapolis
and in their intense sense of duty and their to serve.
One sought to be a marine.
The other a seal
remembering the times.
It didn't take a fortune teller to guess where this would lead them both
okay
to war in Iraq or Afghanistan or both
and to war.
It did lead them extracting from them long separations from their families as
they grew into the full realization of their roles as combat leaders,
but it also extracted from them their last full measure,
their young lives.
Okay.
Willingly sacrificed for their country and these causes.
Tom Mannion has done us a great service in initiating the effort to tell this
story.
Okay?
Yes,
it's about war,
but it's less a history of two wars than it is about the human experience of war
and what this newest generation of American warriors has experienced.
It ties together these precious young lives and their growth together as
warriors,
as leaders
and his brothers.
This book celebrates what we hear more and more frequently that these young
Americans on who's broad,
strong shoulders,
we have fought two wars and who have kept the wolf from the door in a numerable.
Other places are the new greatest generation
with less than 1% of our population in uniform.
Fewer and fewer Americans bear the brunt of the responsibility for military
service and fewer and fewer understand the sacrifices made by men like Travis
and Brendan and they're precious troops.
All of us who fought in these wars now pray that in the end the outcomes will
justify the cost to America and it's allies.
Those of us left behind must ensure the sacrifices were not in vain
and that these lives lost.
We'll have meaning and purpose now
and in the future
and that is the forward
of a book called brothers forever.
Then that foreword was written by John Allen,
who's a retired four star Marine Corp General
and the book which is about Travis Mannion and Brendan Looney
is written by retired marine corps,
Colonel Tom Mannion,
Travis's Dad,
and we are honored today to have colonel Mannion on the podcast.
To give us some insight into the lives of these two amazing men.
Carl Mandian,
welcome and thank you so much for coming on.
Thanks for having me here guys.
Honored to have you on here and
I guess with a story like this,
we might as well go a little bit back to the beginning and a lot of Travis's
life and folks that listen to podcast or that you may remember the name Travis
Mannion because when Brian Stan was on,
he talked quite a bit about about Travis and how much Travis helped Brian try to
learn how to wrestle.
Try,
no offense,
Brian,
he did his best to teach you,
but it was never your best skillset,
but obviously wrestling was a big part of his life and I'm going to go to the
book now and here we go.
He attended classes,
studied and wrote his papers,
but always thought wrestling would best prepare him for being a warrior and
leader on the battlefield.
This belief was reinforced by the qualities he saw in Captain Doug Zembiec
Zenbeck a two time all American wrestler at Navy who attended as many practices
and meets as he could and frequently sparred with Travis
be a battle ax.
Zen Beck told him,
hurl yourself into your opponent.
I think that's good advice.
Just generally in life.
That's Doug.
Sure.
The a battleax zen back in 1995 naval academy graduate had a big impact on
Travis in the young wrestlers eyes.
The gritty,
tough,
seemingly invincible warrior embodied everything.
He wanted to become a skilled marine officer who used the wrestling mat to
develop himself into a leader who commanded respect.
Travis was a high school and college wrestling star after a strong junior year
at navy,
which featured several epic matches against nationally ranked opponents.
He was presented the Naval Academy's Weems award for dedication and leadership
as a preseason top 20 wrestler going into his senior season,
Travis didn't want to simply win matches and meets.
He wanted to dominate and help lead the meat.
Mitch Shipman to a championship.
So we do talk about wrestling a decent amount because we're heavy into
grappling.
So he was just started wrestling at a kit.
Yeah,
he started real early.
He a youth wrestling up through high school.
But um,
like a lot of these guys at navy,
he did a lot of different things.
He did football and Lacrosse as well.
But wrestling was the,
the sport that he really gravitated towards.
Yeah.
Well there's something that makes people gravel gravitate towards wrestling and
combat sports in general,
especially if you're a guy that's in the combat.
Yeah.
You know,
there's something that's beautiful about it and so he's going now the Penn state
open,
it's like the 2004 tournament his senior year.
He's got a hurt shoulder that he'd hurt his junior year.
I'm going back to the book here.
The prudent,
the Purdue wrestler slammed his struggling opponent to the ground for a take
down with Travis injured shoulder thumping squarely on the red and yellow.
Matt,
his right arm was already numb.
And this first blow left Travis with almost no strength to is to attempt the
scape in a sport built on hand to hand combat.
One Hand is almost always no match for to the match ended in an 11 to zero
shutout
and that,
so that's a senior year,
tough day,
tough year.
You know,
he had a great junior year and had his shoulder that was giving them problems
and instead of getting a second opinion,
he went under the knife and it was a disaster.
So,
uh,
start out his senior year looking forward to big year and could never get the
shoulder going again.
And I'm actually one depends date open with that bed shoulder.
I don't know how he did it and uh,
the rest of the year.
But um,
yeah,
the,
the year just didn't turn out well for him.
It's very,
very disappointing for him because he had worked so hard towards getting to the
nationals and being an all American and he had everything going his way.
But you know,
the injury just does zap them.
Yeah.
And,
and
obviously zap them and I can't,
I never put that much effort into a sport when I was in,
when I was in high school,
I didn't,
I didn't do it.
Am I,
am I,
am I kind of a loser because of that little bit.
Little bit,
little bit.
But I never was that into a sport.
And so I,
but I saw people that I knew and you definitely see it in,
in once you get in the teams and you meet guys and they put so much into that
sport,
then something like that happens.
It's crushing.
I didn't think this was a good little pickup that he got.
After a brief moment of silence,
the assistant coach gave Travis or reason to perk up telling the future military
officer that though has seen senior wrestling season was over.
It was now time for him to devote all his energy to becoming a marine.
Yeah.
And it's um,
coach Joel showered.
He's now the back at navy,
went to air force for a couple of years and came back.
He's now the head coach down,
but a great coach,
great mentor.
And by the way,
it was a good friend of Doug's in Beck's too.
So it's like it comes full circle.
And I want to say that Joel would have been a warrior and a marine too.
He was a national champion,
Iowa,
three time finalists for Dan Gable.
If you know anything about wrestling.
Yeah,
he's,
he's the real deal.
That's awesome.
And,
and it's interesting because in the book here,
you know,
you kind of start off with that story and you can see some definite strength of
character from,
from Travis.
And then you take a little backstep and you talk about early in his academy,
a career,
he doesn't want to do it.
And it's,
he decides,
I don't want to stay at the academy.
I want to go to a regular college.
I'm out.
Right.
And he leaves.
And I thought one of the best things about this was,
you know,
when,
when you,
when you talk to him about it,
and I'll go to the book here,
you know who Travis comes to you and says,
Hey,
I'm leaving the academy.
And like I said in the beginning,
you're a marine.
You could,
I can't imagine you could have been any prouder than having your son go to the
Naval Academy.
And then the disappointment you must have had when you said,
oh,
you don't want to go there anymore,
but this is what you said to them.
Going back to the book,
look,
this is your call and your decision.
Tom told his son who he always believed could excel at the naval academy and
beyond,
but I think you're making a big mistake.
How did you know that the one of the bad things you could've done was like force
him to stay there,
which you must have decided in your head like,
okay,
I,
if I forced him to stay here,
he's going to hate it and he'll be miserable and,
and he won't put any effort into it.
I mean,
we,
I get asked all the time,
but what do you do with your kids?
How much do you pressure them?
How did you come to that conclusion that that was the right move?
He's sorta how I always work with him,
you know,
I'm try to treat them,
is uh,
a man and let him make his own decisions,
giving them advice,
coach him.
But at the end of the day,
he's going to have to make those decisions.
And you know,
this was no different.
You know,
I,
I was extremely disappointed,
but,
um,
you know,
he,
I had a buddy there that was a battalion officer at the Naval Academy and he
gave him a hard time about leaving.
And
was that a major Gardner?
Yeah,
yeah.
Lieutenant Colonel Gardner and,
and Corky gave him a hard time and said,
Tom,
I'm not letting them leave.
Let them go home for the holidays.
He'll change his mind.
And sure enough,
he came home and said,
no,
I'm going,
I'm leaving.
And I still remember quirky called me up and he said,
you know,
Tom,
if he ever,
he did great here.
If he ever wants to come back,
you know,
he will probably consider it.
I say quirky.
There's,
there's no way he's coming back.
He's,
he's done.
And uh,
and sure enough,
you know what I mean?
He came back to me later
on that,
uh,
that following spring,
late spring to some other college,
yeah,
Drexel got a call from the wrestling coach come on down because I've just given
him so much trouble at home coach today.
You got a scholarship come on down.
So he left as soon as you could get out of the house.
And uh,
so you let him make his own decision.
You just made him pay for it on a daily basis.
He didn't pay for it.
So that's when,
when I,
I didn't know that and I could not believe that they let him back in.
I mean,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
it's very,
very unusual.
And if you're out there and you're at the Naval Academy right now,
and I know,
I know he got quite a,
quite a few listeners at the,
at the Naval Academy,
and at the end,
at west point as well,
don't think you're going to get into that kind of treatment.
You need to just stay there.
Just me.
It's going to be worth it.
You ain't gonna be followed travels,
man.
You know,
on this one.
No.
Pulled off a miracle and that one it really was cause unbelievable.
And he gets back in,
I mean I guess with his wrestling skills cause he did well,
did well academically,
did well on the wrestling team as a freshman.
But you know,
beyond anything else when he quit,
it's interesting because you know,
he,
he quit and he left and it made him really realize what he was missing.
Yeah.
And when he went back in to talk to people about going back,
he had the passion,
he knew exactly what he wanted to do and they could see it in them.
You know what,
I would have conversations with guys that were kind of thinking about their,
their navy career.
And there's a big,
there's a,
there's a transition that happens mentally with people and that is if they feel
trapped,
they want to escape,
the minute that they don't feel trapped anymore,
then they're like,
oh,
I want to go back in that cage.
So you got it.
If you can get them mentally out of the cage,
which is probably what,
uh,
what Lieutenant Colonel Gardner was trying to do is to go home for the weekend.
Let's see what it's like outside the cage and you're going to want to come back
into the cage.
It didn't work that time,
but I'm always knew it was a longer time outside the cage.
So when guys would come to me and they'd say,
you know,
I'm thinking about getting out,
I'd say I'd say I wouldn't go,
no,
don't get out.
Cause then that's,
that's tightening the cage on them.
I'd say,
yeah man,
start looking at what you can do on the outside.
You know,
why don't you go get a job.
There's some good jobs,
you know,
they got some good jobs you can get,
you can be an executive.
There's,
you know,
you could,
there's probably a good cubicle that would have a nice computer,
add it for you and everything I've done.
But I would not even be sarcastic about it.
I just try and make them start thinking about what regular,
I mean when you're in the seal teams,
it's a ridiculously good life.
I mean it's,
So the minute you start looking at normal jobs in the world,
you want to get back in the cage.
So now he comes back and he ends up with a new roommate,
new roommate at the Naval Academy named Brendan Looney and I'm going to the book
here,
Brendan and Travis,
who carried the burden of being division one athletes along with their academic
and drilling responsibility.
Rarely if ever complained just after the start of the 2001 fall semester,
Travis and Brendan met up for an early morning.
The restaurant and football player both had practice later on that afternoon.
But as to varsity athletes who want it to be the best,
they were determined to work harder than everyone else.
After talking about the start of the NFL season,
they're mid jog conversation shifted to their backgrounds.
They had a lot in common,
including the love of sports and their love of country.
Both midshipmen had been raised,
Catholic and tight knit families,
although Brendan's was a little larger with Brent.
Brendan had for a total of five,
I think total of five siblings.
And so now we're introducing,
you know,
Brendan Ludy into the end of the story here.
And I actually knew Brendan slightly because when he was a seal,
he went through the training that I ran out here on the west coast or the west
coast seal teams and just a stud,
you know,
that's you just stud.
And the one thing I,
I,
well one of the things I remember about him was
I was not,
you know,
the,
the most caring and affectionate instructor as uh,
as,
uh,
when I was running that training and he,
he know and guys would get a little,
you know,
kind of freaked out sometimes when I'd be talking to them about the decisions
that they were making during the training.
And,
and he would usually just be smiling at me like yet,
hey sir,
got it.
It makes sense.
Or you know,
with a smile on his face,
just a stud,
just a straight up stud.
And
so these guys are now fall 2001,
and we know what's coming next.
September 11th comes and you know,
our country is under attack going to the book here and the entire Naval Academy
student body realized that after graduation they would become part of a fighting
force that was now at war.
And you know,
that's the whole military instantly thought that,
you know,
we were all thinking,
oh,
here we go.
Yeah,
we had,
um,
in 2004 it started to come home to us,
it navy,
you know,
we had a JP Blecksmith we'd lost in the battle of Fallujah.
Ronnie Winchester was lost over there around the same time,
um,
both football players,
you know,
and now Travis,
his senior year football teams coming out with the flag and they got Ronnie and
jps jerseys draped over the bench,
you know,
and it was,
it was coming home for all of us.
And he had guys like Doug's in coming back from the battle of Fallujah and
talking about what that was all about,
being in the wrestling room,
wrestling with Travis,
you know,
was was all over at navy.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a total game changer.
No,
it was,
it was definitely like that in the seal teams to,
you know,
we went from,
what was it,
years and years since Vietnam because we had some little,
you know,
there was Panama,
there was Grenada,
there was Somalia,
there were some things that happened,
but those were little flashes of,
of combat action and all of a sudden we were facing and what's now turned out to
be,
you know,
a decade and a half or more worth of war.
Unbelievable.
These guys,
you know,
as you said,
they're,
their intensity is just,
you know,
they,
they might have been intense before,
but now their intensity is going to be through the roof.
They know what's coming.
In May of 2004 Brendan and Travis graduated with their Naval Academy classmates
and were commissioned as US military officer's.
Brendan would go to serve in the naval intelligence community.
While Travis would head to the basic school for Marine Corps officers in
Quantico,
Virginia.
So
Brendan didn't get picked up for the seal teams right out of right out of the
academy,
which is fairly normal.
It's a,
they only have a very small number of openings for guys in the Naval Academy.
And you can imagine how competitive it is to have a guy like Brendan not get
picked up is crazy.
And so he goes out to go good to go into the Intel community.
And then Travis heads down to heads down to Quantico for the little bit of the
basic school.
And actually this was interesting and I,
I wasn't aware of this,
but the lacrosse championships,
those happen after they graduate their seat after they get commissioned it.
The way it read in here,
it was like it happened after they got commissioned.
Well was,
it was actually,
it was the championship was after graduation weekend.
Same,
same weekend.
Who's been more than a weekend?
Yeah.
So and,
and Brendan at some point the Naval Academy started playing Lacrosse.
Yeah.
Brendan was a football player.
He went there,
it was recruited for football.
And,
um,
played football for a couple of years,
dressed and played and decided that he wanted to go out for Lacrosse.
Um,
both of his brothers were playing lacrosse and he went out there and just picked
up a stick,
as you said earlier,
just such a natural athlete,
so gifted,
big,
strong,
and uh,
you know,
picked up a stick.
And by the time he was a senior in that,
that championship game,
if you ask anyone who was the heart and soul,
that team,
it was number 40,
Brendan looney.
I mean he,
he led them all the way to the championship.
He and his two brothers were the heart and soul of the team.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
And so they get to the championship game.
I'm going back to the book against Syracuse though.
Navy followed with a goal Syracuse one,
it's third championship and five years in eighth overall title Brendan was
absolutely crushed by the 14 to 13 defeat.
This is supposed to be Navy's Day.
It would take some time for the loss to sink in.
But Brendan,
who had just played his final collegiate game and everyone associated with the
Navy program knew deep down that the team's improbable four run had been a truly
amazing feat.
I don't think I've ever felt this low man.
Brendan grumbled,
we should have won that game.
I know Travis replied,
but don't do what I did to myself in wrestling.
What do you mean?
Brendan asked when I lost that match and Texas I fought,
my whole life was over.
I hadn't been that miserable since I quit the academy.
But there are bigger things out there.
Think of what we're probably going to be doing a year or two from now.
So same thing,
you know,
a little bit of glory getting crushed,
right?
A little glory getting crushed at the end there.
And you know,
Travis say,
look man,
and this is true and I say this all the time,
you know,
sports with a ball and the referee and all that stuff,
it's a game.
You know,
and these guys are about to go into something that's no longer a game.
And that's what Travis recognized and it help Brendan see that
going back to the book now that he was a young second lieutenant training at the
basic school in Quantico,
Virginia was difficult for Travis to imagine that the months after graduation
can be even more challenging,
but in fall of 2004 the harsh reality of war became more personal for Travis
Brendan and their fellow Naval Academy graduates
on September 2nd,
2004 Marine First Lieutenant
Ronald Winchester,
a driven popular former navy football player,
became the first combat death and the Naval Academy's 2001 class when he was
killed in a roadside bomb attack in Iraq.
I'll on bar province less than 48 hours later,
Travis and his fellow navy wrestling alarms were hit by another freight train
upon learning that Marine Second Lieutenant Brett Harmon,
a friend and teammate who had graduated in 2003 was murdered during the melee at
a North Carolina State University football tailgate.
And that's a story that,
that's the story that that Brian Stan told as well.
Okay.
When a tragedy that was,
I mean,
you know,
he was stepping in to help out and the guy came back and killed him and his
friend was hit everyone hard.
Brett was a really popular guy
and so coach Sharat,
he,
and again,
this is something that Brian Stan talked about,
you know,
would when they were heading to the funeral and here we go.
Let's do an exercise.
This is,
this is coach rod talking.
Let's do an exercise.
I'd like you to both close your eyes and picture that you're leaving a building.
A friend picks you up and takes you to a place where people are somber,
crying and there seems to be an audience.
Then you realize you're at your own funeral.
Write down a few words about what you'd want a family member or a person of
faith to say when reflecting on the lives of Travis Mannion or Brian.
Stan.
Stan nodded and after a few minutes of pondering what to write,
started drawing down a sentence about one day being remembered as a good
husband,
a loving father,
and a US marine.
Travis went through several pieces of paper before settling on one sentence.
Yeah.
Travis Mannion was a man on afraid to stand for what was right.
And as I mentioned earlier,
Travis started helping out Brian with his wrestling and he,
and eventually as Brian started fighting,
because Brian's a maniac,
started doing MMA matches and he needed a corner man.
So he needed to have the rest of corner man.
And so again,
this is something that we covered with Brian Stann,
but for if he didn't hear it that first time there,
you know,
you got Brian's about to fight.
He's literally,
you know,
whatever,
20 minutes,
half an hour from getting in the cage and fight and somebody,
and Travis gets a phone call and Brian can tell something's going on and,
and Brian saying,
hey,
tell me what's going on.
Travis says,
I'll tell you later,
Brian stances.
You tell me now Travis looks away after the fight.
No,
give it to me straight.
Brian demanded what's going on.
And then Travis tells him JP Black Smith was killed in Fallujah last night.
So again,
your point,
is that right?
Yeah.
These are people,
you know,
real close to home
and it was tough for,
for Brian,
it's tough for anyone that's sitting on the sidelines,
which is what you feel like.
You feel like you can't,
you,
you want to help and you can't do anything your bat,
you're literally thousands of miles away.
And that's what these guys are are feeling.
Yeah,
a lot.
A lot of frustration there.
But I think also at the same time it,
it built a lot of resolve with those guys.
I mean they were determined to make sure that they honored them in their service
and work hard to do all they could do to make a difference.
Now there was a story told in here that I,
I definitely wanted to go over because
yeah,
it revealed a little bit,
um,
uh,
about Travis.
To me that was a little hard to pick up a little earlier and that was obviously
that he was funny as hell and didn't mind taking some risks.
So these guys were in a training situation and you know,
Travis was on the radio and he's giving commands and he's given orders and
they're being listened to by some higher up training officer that's kind of
monitoring what they're doing.
And so Travis is going back and forth on the radio with his guys.
They're doing some training.
And then as Travis pressed the button too on his radio to relay the final order,
allowed familiar voice suddenly overtook the frequency.
Lieutenant,
this is coyote six the voice said,
I'm not really sure what you're trying to do out here,
but you're not following proper radio procedure.
Sir Travis asked,
puddle puzzled,
you need to figure out what you're trying to do because I sure as hell can't
tell by listening to your orders over to this radio,
the rising voice said,
do things right or do us all a favor and just go home.
So okay,
Travis,
thanks about that.
And he just keeps his radio and says,
yes sir.
So they're continuing.
They're doing a little bit more.
Travis has continued to direct his troops and his training operation.
And
finally the voice comes on again.
Lieutenant Mannion,
this is [inaudible] six
he said his dozens of eyes rolled.
I have a cold.
I have to ask you a question son.
Do you have any idea what the hell you're doing out there?
Radio is dead silent for almost 30 uncomfortable seconds as everyone
waited for the young second lieutenants response.
No Sir.
Travis had,
Travis said,
but I did stay at a holiday inn express last night.
No,
for those of you that aren't in the military,
when you key up on the radio,
it's not like I'm just cracking a joke to my boss did just me and him.
No,
there's like dozens and dozens.
If not,
you know,
40 50 maybe even a hundred people that just heard you say that.
So that was a ballsy comment.
Funny,
risky,
but kind of showed it's classic.
It's great because that tells the guys,
hey look,
we're going to get through this.
We're going to,
we're going to push it on and we're gonna make this happen.
So I thought that,
yeah,
guys from first recon shared that story when they came,
it came to our place.
And it was typical Travis,
you know,
and he said he just like everything got silent,
the coyote shut up and they said when they got back to the headquarters they
will want it to meet this new lieutenant.
You didn't catch me off from,
from quoting six on that code is six got quiet.
That was it.
Yeah.
You got punk so hard.
He just,
he just shut down.
He probably couldn't help but understand that.
Yeah,
that was,
that was brazen.
But that was a good joke.
You know what too.
I bet if he's a good guy and he's putting pressure on his troops,
he might've just,
so he might've just set back from his radio and just thought to himself,
respect.
I respect that.
We've got to respect what words coming out from the Holiday Inn Express
as awesome.
So now we fast forward,
we get to Travis's first deployment and he's in Al Anbar province and with first
recon battalion and here we go as the first reconnaissance battalions,
maintenance management management officer at Camp Fallujah.
His responsibilities,
which were focused on making sure vehicles we're correctly allocated,
fueled and repaired.
We're undoubtedly important,
but sitting on the sidelines while others went outside the wire to fight was
definitely not what the marine had envisioned when he was back training.
So he got assigned as a logistics officer?
He did,
yeah,
he was,
um,
he actually had intel officers his first choice because they have the sniper
squads and,
um,
he had infantry for a while and then he said,
you know what,
I think I'd like to work with the sniper.
So he switched it and he always thought since he switched it at the end,
that's how he ended up being a logistician.
So,
so he always,
um,
you know,
was kicking himself for that.
But you know,
when he went out there,
started to work in logistics,
realize how important it was,
the mission,
I think he was still a little frustrated for sure.
But,
um,
he started really integrate with first recon and actually Colonel Higgins,
the CEO said,
look,
when you come back from this second tour,
we're going to give you a recap.
Attune.
So he was pretty jazzed up about that and looking forward to,
to getting a recon batoon and uh,
you know,
it was part of why when he was over there as a Mitt team member,
he was doing logistics as an advisor,
but also he was also taken the,
the platoons out on patrols probably more than anyone over there.
I mean,
he was that sort of the way he was.
he was going to get ready,
so he was like,
okay,
another patrol.
I'm going,
yeah,
I got it.
It's a,
I mean,
obviously logistics wins wars.
Yeah.
That being said,
I don't think Travis was the logistics kind of guy.
And in logistics they truly do.
I mean,
if you can't get bullets and beans,
you're not going to win the war.
That's the way it is.
And that's one of the great things about the Marine Corps,
the way they do their spread and they put really high quality guys in every
aspect of marine corps,
including logistics.
But yeah,
I can imagine he was,
he was a pretty frustrated about that.
Well,
frustrated.
And now the Marine Corps gives then an annual award to the logistician of the
year and it's the Travis Manion logistician of the year.
Okay.
That's all.
That's awesome.
You know,
and,
and Sherat Sharat cause that how you pronounce his name.
No,
share it,
share it.
Share.
So share it.
I thought this was another awesome piece of advice from,
from Sharon.
You know,
who,
you know,
Travis had reached out and said,
hey,
you know,
it's,
it's great to be here.
I'm doing the best I can,
you know,
but I'm definitely getting frustrated.
I want to go outside the wire and share it says
learn everything you can.
Every second you can study the tactics,
study the,
study the culture and know them more importantly,
know yourself and be vigilant not to let up on yourself.
Preparing for the unexpected.
So that's just incredible advice.
You don't know.
And,
and it doesn't matter what situation you were in,
you try and make yourself better and you want to actually,
I worked for,
for one of the senior seal admirals that when September 11th kicked off,
he was in charge of acquisitions at the Pentagon as a,
as a captain.
And you,
you know,
here's everyone going to war and he's,
doing acquisitions,
which for those of you that aren't military,
that means it's high level logistics.
And,
and,
and something that he told me that always stuck with me was,
you know,
he was the same thing as,
as,
as Travis.
And he's frustrated.
He,
Oh,
here I am in the Pentagon every day.
And what he told me was,
you know what I said to myself,
Jocko,
this is my foxhole.
I'm gonna fight,
you know,
so his foxhole wasn't the Pentagon dealing with paper,
and that's what he did.
And he knew that he,
that was his,
that was what he had to do.
And now he's going to do it to the best of his ability.
And,
and hearing this from Sharat Sharat share it,
share it.
I'm going to keep it.
Yeah,
well Joe was a great mentor.
You know,
he always had solid advice for Travis and the other guys that wrestled at navy
for sure.
All this being said about,
you know,
logistics being inside the wire.
Oh,
logistics.
When you're running convoys all the time.
Those logistics guys,
Army,
Marine Corps,
Navy Seabees,
we had cvs that ran logistics.
You're doing convoys and you're doing convoys do down heavily laden IED streets.
So there was all kinds of logistics.
As a matter of fact,
you know the,
there's a lot of female logisticians that deployed to Iraq and Afghanistan.
Oh,
they're supposed to be in a non combat role.
Well guess what they got after it?
They had to the right in the middle of it all.
You're in a convoy.
Yeah.
So speaking of that,
back to the book,
during one late night evening convoy through Fallujah,
the deafening thunder of an IED shattered the relative tranquility of first
reconnaissance battalion patrol.
The group of marines had been attacked before,
but this was the first time that Travis was with them during a hostel incident,
keeping his composure while following orders of the more experienced officers.
Travis,
his heart pumping and ears ringing helped evacuate a marine who was wounded in
the attack.
So again,
might've been in logistics,
but you're still,
those guys are out there right in the middle of it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Now he comes home from that deployment.
I'm going back to the book.
Iraq changed newly promoted First Lieutenant Travis Mannion for the better as
the Marines,
mom,
dad,
sister,
and several naval academies,
buddies all noticed he was still the same.
Travis who had willingly traded Doyle's town for one of the world's most
dangerous places.
But after returning to the United,
Travis carried with him at an aura of seriousness and quiet self confidence that
was unfamiliar to some of his closest friends and loved ones.
When Travis talked about life,
he acknowledged its fragility.
Having felt the pulse of an IED blast and seeing dead bodies in the streets
for a young marine who had just spent eight months in Fallujah,
it was almost impossible not to mature no matter what Travis was doing.
He was acutely aware that every single day Americans,
Iraqis and Afghans were fighting and often dying.
I love the fact that that paragraph starts off by saying that that deployment to
Iraq change Travis for the better because so often w you know,
we here and civilians get told and the public gets told that the war does all
these horrible things to people and,
and they fail to realize that in many cases,
war makes you a better person.
Well,
you could,
you could definitely see the difference with Travis.
I mean,
he,
he went over there and eight months later he was a different guy.
I mean,
he was so much more focused and mature and,
and you know,
he had a chance to lead over there in these incredible situations where you have
to make quick decisions.
And,
you know,
he,
uh,
he got a lot from it.
I could just sort of see it in the time I spent with him.
And He,
and the other thing about it,
I think is like appreciating what you have.
I mean,
to saw that so much from him,
you know,
when he was back here,
was just like,
wow,
this is the greatest place in the world.
You know,
there's no,
no doubt about that.
That's something I think everybody that deploys comes back and you add a
minimum,
you're going to appreciate what we have in America.
Things like bathrooms.
Yeah.
Because over there you're,
you're only in a Porta potties,
right?
Or you're in the field,
but you're in Porta potties.
In the summertime we used to call them the Blue Saunas beat because they're blue
colored plastic.
Right.
And then inside it's,
you know,
it's 120 degrees outside.
So inside the Blue Sauna,
Eh,
it's,
you know,
160 degrees and you don't want to leave the doors open because that's just
nasty.
So you just leave the blue sauna shut.
Yeah.
Do when you come home from that?
You get to a protector appreciate off thing.
And a meanwhile,
this time Brendan,
he now has gone to on a deployment to South Korea,
working as an Intel officer and doing that in,
in,
even in doing that,
he felt like he had,
you know,
a lot more to do.
And this is when he focused on,
you know,
he wanted to be a seal.
Now he's going,
yes,
I need to be a seal.
He told his girlfriend who he had met while they were going to the naval
academy.
Amy,
I've got to do more.
Brendan said during a late night phone conversation,
Travis is there,
my other buddies are there and I want to be there with them.
When Amy reminded him of the dangers,
his friends like Travis,
we're facing,
Brendan was undeterred,
I should be in the fight.
He insisted.
Now there's an issue here and actually I,
I was,
I talked about this,
how surprising it was that Brendan didn't get picked up for the seals out of the
naval academy and I,
and I forgot the reason.
If there's a really distinct reason called him,
he was colorblind,
he was colorblind and you can't be colorblind in the seal teams.
At least you're not.
He's the first guy to get a waiver.
You're not supposed to be colorblind in the seal teams and that's why he didn't
get picked up.
I still remember that call from Travis.
He said,
dad got great news.
Brandon just got selected for the seals.
Navy seals just got one hell of a leader.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
And before he got picked up,
and this is probably helped him in back to the book in August,
2006 Brendan deployed to Fallujah where he gathered,
analyzed intelligence for combat missions,
including operations carried out by seals.
So actually I was in Ramadi at this time,
so Rwandese,
I dunno,
40 30 miles from Fallujah and he,
he was working,
he must have been working at our intel shop.
And so the Intel he was gathering,
we would go out and prosecute those targets and he's working with working with
seals and that that must have helped them out
back to the book.
Meanwhile,
Travis was making another visit to the east coast for the Christening of his
niece,
Maggie rose [inaudible] give her,
so,
so he's Christian,
his daughter.
And also he found out now that he's going back to Iraq and that this is another
thing that he's sharing that news as the,
as,
as your granddaughter's getting christened,
Travis is telling you,
Hey,
I'm going back to Iraq and he's going back with the,
with the,
what is it?
The third battalion,
Second Brigade,
first Iraqi army division,
military transition team,
Mitt team.
I said that in the opening,
so little,
little bit about the Mitt teams.
I've talked about the various levels of comfort that you have in the military or
that we had in Iraq and and how you know us guys in the seal teams generally for
the most part,
high level of comfort,
you know,
we would get to a place we would bring,
we would build a gym immediately.
We would have our CBS constructed Jim.
If we didn't have one,
we would get,
you know,
we would get video or Internet service,
we would live pretty good,
we'd get food shipped and we would pretty good.
Now that being said,
of course there was special ops guys that are way out in the middle of nowhere
living on a farm somewhere and that's living rough.
There were some people that were even more comfortable.
There were some headquarters units that had swimming pools,
and we'll say that again as swimming pools.
So there's some headquarters areas,
you know,
if you got into the Green Zone in Baghdad,
you're,
yeah,
I'm on deployment in Iraq.
I'm going to hand out to the swimming pool for a few minutes.
And you know,
there's,
there's those,
there's those kind of living,
and then you get,
you know,
you got in Ramadi,
we had the conventional guys that were living in the combat outpost in the city,
real rough living.
And then you go one step refer and where you end up with his mid teams and Mitt
teams.
So this,
the,
the stands for military transition team,
and this is when you are the direct advisor to an Iraqi battalion.
And in this case it was the three,
two one.
You're gonna hear me say that a bunch of the third battalion,
Second Brigade,
first Iraqi army division.
So this is,
this is a battalion of Iraqi soldiers supposed to be six or 700,
probably a lot less than that because they were generally highly undermanned.
But the Mitt teams had a really,
really hard job.
Oh re an incredibly hard job.
It was,
you know,
we did advising to the Iraqi soldiers and we work with the Iraqi soldiers side
by side and these guys did it not just on the battlefield but with everything
that they did.
Helping them with their pay,
helping them learn how to,
how to do the logistics side that you mentioned.
Travis,
who's doing the Mitt teams.
Just nothing but respect for the met team has.
And on top of that we go out with the seal teams.
You know,
we had great training and then we had other seals with us.
Mint tea we'd have,
we'd have a minimum,
usually have like six to eight seals with us.
When we go mid teams.
Sometimes those guys are going out with one other Mitt team guy out with 40
Iraqi soldiers.
Poorly trained,
poorly motivated.
Yeah.
They lived right there with them and they were totally embedded with them.
So eating the same food,
tough job.
A horse.
I remember that.
The uh,
the call from Travis when it first heard that and I was just like,
wow,
you know,
much more comfortable as a dad with Travis with 200 marines.
Yeah.
The comfort level.
The comfort levels in comparable.
Yeah.
Between being with 200 marines and being with 200 Iraqis,
it's these completely,
it's that the level of risk is so much higher.
There was a win.
There was a Mitt team that came out in Ramadi and they were turning over to Mitt
team,
the ongoing milliliter leader and the offgoing meant leader returned over.
They got attacked.
Both of them got killed.
One attack.
That's how much risk that you're taking with these these Mitt teams situations.
Well,
the other thing about these guys is,
you know they were,
they were gone out in,
in patrols with them and you know if they're going to train them the right way,
they were out front.
They,
one of the things we've,
Travis,
last time I talked to him,
one of the last times at home,
I said,
Travis,
you're an advisor.
Make sure you just told the Iraqis were it needs to be done and step back and
let them execute.
And he was like,
Okay Dad,
I got it.
And I knew,
I knew exactly,
you know what he was going to do.
He's going to lead from the front and that,
that's what he did.
You know,
that's what all those guys were doing.
They were,
you're,
you're out of patrol.
You're right out front with everyone else.
You know,
when the Navy Seals,
uh,
came back,
Eric Greitens was a navy seal with Travis and he said,
you know,
Travis was always there,
every patrol.
So
yeah,
so that's where he gets tasked with and it,
and I'll tell you what,
if you want to get some here in the Mitt team,
you know,
like you said,
you're going to go out in patrols of the rack as you know,
you're going to get after it.
There's no doubt about it.
So nothing but respect for the guys that we worked with a bunch of Mitt teams in
Ramadi,
just outstanding guys doing a really,
really hard job.
Tough,
tough,
unrelenting job.
Well,
you know,
at the end of the day with strategically,
it was the search,
right?
And they put everything behind the mid teams at that point.
You remember in 2006 2007 before Travis left,
he actually had a chance to talk to General Maddis came and talked to his Mitt
team,
but how important that mission was.
So we're putting a lot behind our guys that were embedded with the Iraqis.
Yeah.
And again for those of you that,
just to dig into that strategic piece a little bit more,
our goal was to turnover Iraqi security to the Iraqis and,
and the only way to do that,
and we realize this and that's one of the things that made people realize the
importance of the Mitt teams was you weren't going to do it.
You want to cut to educate them on how to do a combat patrol in the classroom.
You weren't going to educate them on how to do a combat patrol.
Even on a training field.
You needed to take them out and teach them and force them to go out and do these
things.
Cause the Iraqi's,
if they have the,
the,
the had the opportunity to either stay on base or go out on patrol.
A lot of them would do it.
Yeah.
There,
their goal is to stay on base.
Many of them,
many.
And so of course there were some guys that were more motivated,
but a lot of them were just,
they just want to survive,
right?
They just want to survive.
So strategically that's what we had to do was we had to take them out and give
them on the job training and simultaneously pushed them to,
to go out and try and lower some of the level of violence out in the various
cities.
So,
hey,
at this time also,
as you mentioned,
uh,
Brendan got approved for his,
for his lat transfers called Allat transference or now he knows that he's going
to,
he knows that he's going to go to buds,
go to buds and,
and,
and be a seal or at least try and be a CEO.
But I bet he was pretty confident.
I'm certain of that.
One of the first things Travis did here,
he's,
he's going,
he's got a couple more days left.
He meets up with Marine Major Steve Cantrell and assistant navy wrestling coach
and they go to New York,
Travis and Cantrell decide to spend a few days in New York City where Cantrell
at arranged a visit to New York fire departments rescue one headquarters located
in Hell's kitchen rescue one had become a revered place over the past five
years.
A small Manhattan building,
which was still fully functioning,
had been the home base for 11 firefighters,
almost half the unit who were killed in the September 11th,
2001 terrorist attacks as they were leaving the firehouse.
One firefighter and former marine,
thank Travis for coming out.
Lieutenant Mannion,
I want you to have these hats and shirts said the Marine Corps vet veteran,
no matter how crazy things get over there,
you can always put one of these on and remember what you're fighting for.
Then he comes home and he's got that,
that rescue one hat with the,
with the rescue one fire department,
New York logo on the front and nine 1101 never forget on the back.
And he says to you,
Dad,
I want you to have this and please wear it while I'm gone.
No matter what happens,
always remember that this is what we're fighting for.
Yeah.
I always remember that,
that discussion we had,
you know,
down the hallway and so impacted him to be there with those guys.
And he actually went up there to,
to thank them for all they had done.
And he said,
dad,
they couldn't thank me enough for,
for my tour and what I was about to do.
And,
and he was,
you know,
he,
he got real serious about it and always remember that was one of the last
conversations I had with him.
An interesting side note to that story.
So my wife and I,
after we lost Travis,
went up to rescue one talk to the guys.
We were up there and they sort of remember maybe you know somebody coming
through and,
but it never really clicked for the guys who are with but great guys.
And you know,
we ended up leaving and never felt like we had the connection that we expected
because Travis had talked about it's so much and a couple of years later,
I'd say about
two years ago.
So what are you talking about?
Like seven,
six,
seven years later.
Well the books out and there's a New York City firefighter that gives his buddy
the book and says,
Hey read this book,
sit mentions rescue one.
So the guys on the treadmill,
he almost off the tram.
I says that that was me.
He had since been transfer.
So Tim Sullivan calls me up and says I'm the guy in the book.
I want to come have a beer with you.
Yeah
that's outstanding.
And that's also the same conversation where you told Travis,
you know,
hey you're an advisor
advise.
Right.
Then let the,
let the Iraqi's execute,
which can be really hard.
It's,
you know,
can be hard cause they won't execute.
It can be hard cause you want to show them how to do it right and and oftentimes
if you don't lead from the front,
not going to happen is how can I have in there?
No.
So
now
your son in law,
Dave and Travis go to a football game and here we go back to the book as they
reach a flight of stairs near the Lincoln financial field.
Exit Dave with a clear hint of humor.
Finally conveyed is concerned.
He was concerned,
you know,
he's concerned about and going overseas and he says,
Hey Travis,
if I tripped you right now,
when you fell down and broke your ankle,
do you think they'd let you sit this deployment out?
He asked.
Travis chuckled at Dave's joke,
but didn't say much in response,
a brief moment of slightly awkward silence followed while drunk and eagles fans
shouted and chanted all around them.
Suddenly Travis spoke up.
You know what though,
Dave Travis said,
we've an unmistakably serious look on his face.
If I don't go,
they're going to send another marine in my place who doesn't have my training,
if not me,
then who?
You know what I mean?
He continued.
It's either me or that other guy who isn't ready.
So I'm the one who has to get the job done.
Okay.
So think about that because you know,
you think back to the,
the time with coach Sharon and Brian Stan and then they're in the plane and
Travis has,
I want to be known as the guy that always,
you know,
stepped forward and did what was right,
if not me,
than who is another way to say it,
right?
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
it's not,
I don't share that because it's unique to Travis,
you know,
I share that because it's an,
and this whole story is really a representation is so many men and women in
uniform,
you know,
it's their story,
but it's a story that can be told about so many and that,
if not me,
then who,
you know,
we,
we use that now at the foundation is sort of drive momentum around,
you know,
what we all need to be thinking about as Americans stepping up and doing the
right thing.
I'll agree with you 100% that there's a lot of people that say things like that.
But you know,
to have an example that someone that's so clearly live that is,
is awesome to look at.
Okay,
now we're getting ready for deployment.
Back to the book,
more than a hundred American troops were killed in Iraq and December,
2006 including Major Meghan Mcclung,
the highest ranking female officer to die in Iraq war and the Iraq war and the
first female Navy Naval Academy graduate to be killed in combat.
And
by the way,
that she was stationed in Ramadi,
I knew her and she was killed along with a another army specialist named Vincent
Permante.
They're killed by big ID on routes sunset,
I think it was.
And also another guy was with her,
a guy named Travis Patrick Quinn,
who was just an unbelievable guy.
And this was a huge loss to lose,
to lose Travis and,
and Megan and in that IED,
right,
I knew both of them and it was just,
just a huge loss.
Never,
never knew her,
but I certainly met her parents,
you know?
Yeah,
she's buried down in Arlington section 60 she
was,
she was just like really just a huge smile all the time.
Are Real go getter,
just making things happen in anyway.
I didn't work with her.
Well you know,
I mean we'd see,
I see you're at brigade meetings cause we were both,
you know,
working with the one,
one a d and you know,
she was just,
yeah,
I got that.
And she was just really positive and,
and she was,
the thing I remember most about her was just her smiling,
you know,
she just had always had a big smile on her face and,
and,
and Travis,
you know what I'm going to do Travis story on here someday.
You know,
Travis was the guy,
he made this,
this PowerPoint brief for how to win the war in Iraq.
And it was a stick figures and it explained like,
Hey,
here's you,
you're an American,
here's this Iraqi and you don't know if this Iraqi is good or bad,
but you know,
who does know these other Iraqis?
And it was just all these stick figures and it's,
it got published,
it got circulated.
That was Travis.
That was Travis Patrick when he spoke Arabic.
Uh,
just a fantastic guy and I'll definitely cover,
there's,
there was a book written about him as well,
so,
hmm.
Incredible people
on,
um,
on her at her grave site in section 60.
It says,
be bold,
be brief,
be gone.
Well she,
well she was indeed all those three things
going on here.
Now Major Doug's and Beck,
the Naval Academy wrestler turned warrior whom Travis admired.
He was killed as well.
Yeah,
it was,
um,
shortly after we lost Travis,
a couple of weeks later,
Doug was over there in Baghdad.
Was killed.
Yeah.
Okay.
He was,
he,
I don't know if you knew him.
I didn't,
I just kind of a big personality at the Naval Academy and had the marines in
Fallujah.
Yeah.
Came back Felicia and yeah.
Quite quite a leader in that.
I really didn't know me there in Travis his junior year,
he was back wrestling with Travis at navy.
They were about the same size.
Doug was a big guy and,
and uh,
see a guy behind the bench yelling and screaming like crazy as trousers out
there.
Wrestling had a really tough match.
He ends up winning like one nothing against this kid from North Carolina.
I said,
Travis,
who is that guy behind the bench?
He said,
dad,
that's Doug's Inback back.
You don't who Doug's him back case.
So that's when I first met Scott at this point.
He hadn't been killed yet.
He was,
he was,
but the point that they were making here that I,
I kind of miss worded was that he was a classmate of,
uh,
of Megan macunx apparently.
Yeah.
Classmates.
And so that was the connection there.
Yeah,
that was a couple.
That was what,
a couple of weeks,
couple of weeks before before,
uh,
Travis arrives that,
you know,
he's getting this news.
Yeah.
Now Travis is back in Fallujah.
Back to the book.
Travis has seen his share of blood but never needed a wash any from his hands.
That all changed in change in January,
less than a month after returned,
returned to Falucia for a second deployment.
Travis and his fellow members went on combat patrols virtually every day,
sometimes running as many as three missions over a punishing 18 hour span in
collusion throughout Iraq,
marine soldiers,
sailors,
airmen,
and Iraqi troops did everything from hunting and surgeons and weapons caches to
disposing of dead bodies.
Adding to three,
two,
one myths,
Challenges.
We're joint patrols with the Iraqis through some of Falucia is most dangerous
sectors.
The Iraqi soldiers would sometimes respond to the slightest sign of violence
with what some u s team members nicknamed the Iraqi death blossom.
When a shot was fired in their direction,
the Iraqis would sometimes form a circle and fire in every direction with little
regard for consequences,
including tragically catching innocent civilians in a crossfire.
Civilian casualties were sometimes unavoidable,
unavoidable reality of war,
but Travis and his fellow marines were determined to use every means at their
disposal to prevent them.
While some Mitt team members understand that,
we became frustrated with the often untrained,
underpaid Iraqi soldiers.
Travis positioned himself as a mentor during lunch.
He would bring his child or that to their mess hall and sit with Nick and Iraqi
translator who helped bridge the gap between us and Iraqi armies.
They not only talked about combat strategy,
but also simple things like soccer.
So this is just pure professionalism.
That's what that is.
Pure profession.
I had a chance to go over to Iraq in 2010 and I met with the Iraqis at Travis
serve with and they said that,
you know,
Lieutenant Man I knew would always come over and sit down and eat with us and
talk with us.
And he always part of what you needed to do,
right?
If you're gonna,
if you're going to be there and be their brother and,
and help them with the mission they had,
you got to be part of what they're doing.
And he understood that.
And I mean,
it's
not like a unlike Brendan would,
you know what I mean?
When you're playing athletics,
you sorta get that teamwork piece,
you know,
you know if you're going to make it work,
you got to all be together.
Yeah.
And it's,
the book makes it sound like it's fairly easy to do that.
It's not,
man,
it's hard.
There's a huge cultural difference between Iraqis in American and,
and you know,
it's not that big of a deal,
but I'll tell you what going,
you know,
you're,
you're overseas.
The one time you can kind of relax is when you get to sit down and eat your
child and you're in the Chow Hall and you're actually fairly well protected.
Most of the time.
You don't have to worry about anything.
You,
you clear your weapon before you go in the Chow Hall.
I mean it's,
it's usually a relatively safe place and you get to relax and get to be around
all your American friends and it's good to,
to deny yourself that.
And now you're going into,
because you know,
at this time you don't,
you can't give full trust to the Iraqi's.
You're,
you're gonna,
you know,
eating with them the conversations or stilted,
it's just not this little thing.
It's a big deal.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a big deal to make that extra effort.
And,
and clearly you how many times,
you know,
I'm,
I'm pretty engaged in my job.
Do you have any times I ate with Iraqis when I was in Iraq on my last
deployment?
Oh Man.
Maybe twice,
maybe twice,
maybe twice.
You know,
because you know,
when I was in a little bit,
I was in a different position,
but maybe twice.
Yeah.
And you know,
at the end of the day they recognize that,
oh,
for sure.
When I went over,
they talked about that quite a bit with me and how they'd recognize that now it
was important to them and he knew that
he absolutely did.
That's the point is that he,
he knew it.
He knew that making that sacrifice,
building those relationships,
that was his primary mission,
or at least one of his primary missions was to build relationships with these
Iraqi soldiers so that they could get to know him so they could build trust
until that they would go out there and do their job.
So professional at all times.
And this is another really good example of of traves Travis's leadership back to
the book.
Just as some US marines became frustrated by the raw battlefield tactics of the
Iraqi's,
which could put all their lives at risks.
Some Iraqi soldiers rolled their eyes when Americans gave them orders,
whereas previous Mu Marine lieutenants had barked instructions that they Iraqi
army leadership.
Travis took a different approach starting with a knock on the door of the Iraqi
Lieutenant Julale.
Good day lieutenant.
I was wondering if I could speak with you about the upcoming raid on the high
value target in the industrial sector.
Travis said through the interpreter.
I was wondering what time you think you would like to execute our mission.
I think 5:00 PM would be a good time to leave.
Julale replied,
my men had a long day and I don't want to keep them up too late.
Okay.
Travis said,
but I'm wondering if you might consider leaving a bit later,
possibly after sunset.
My concern is that our presence during daylight could endanger neighbors who
live near the house.
We're going to strike,
not to mention little children who could be playing in the street.
Respectfully lieutenant,
I wouldn't want to be the one to tell their parents that their son or daughter
might still be alive if we had waited a couple more hours after a pause and a
sip of water.
The Iraqi Knauf officer nodded.
The raid would not start until 8:00 PM so again,
real leadership and I talk about this all the time in here,
you know the real leaders aren't barking orders.
The real leaders are the ones that are flanking and using indirect approaches
with the people that they're trying to influence.
And there's a,
just a phenomenal example of that.
Got some email here,
email coming from Travis,
send it to you,
you'll send it to the family and,
and some of his buddies said to Brendan as well,
here we go.
All my job is definitely going well.
After all the horror stories we hear,
we heard about the Iraqi armor army and their unwillingness to work with the
myths.
They have been very open and willing to listen to advice.
Creating an initial relationship with my counterparts was the right move and it
has allowed me to help them start shaping operations.
There are many dedicated men in this army and it's been an eye opening
experience so far.
The Best Ias,
that's our Iraqi army soldier.
The best ias are definitely dedicated to their cause and have a warrior
mentality that rivals some Americans.
However,
there are still those enemies out there that wish us to fail.
There's a lot of work left to do,
but the city is definitely at a different place than it was last year.
I really feel that is,
it is at a critical point where if the present situation continues to progress,
it could have huge positive impact in other areas.
Also,
I've found good balance between my logistics job and my company advisor role.
Although going on operations definitely requires a good amount of time.
I'm able to work with a battalion logistics officer on a fairly regular basis.
I also appreciate all the good food and gear that has been sent.
Workouts and your support have definitely helped keep me going.
As I said before,
we're pretty busy.
If I wanted to take a minute to thank you guys for everything and keep you
updated,
please continue to write.
I enjoy your updates as well.
Take care and I'll talk to you soon.
Semper fi,
Travis.
Yeah,
it was one of his,
um,
last notes home,
but you can see,
I mean,
he's a glass half full type of guy.
You know,
we're,
we're getting it done.
We're working hard.
We're going to make a difference.
You know,
that's sort of how he approached everything and,
and that was what he was trying to share.
Interesting thing also about the logistics were all,
because when I was over there talking to the,
the logistics guy that he worked with sorta in a kidding way,
said you have lieutenant Mannion was a horrible logistics officer and they
started laughing.
He said he's never,
he was always on patrol.
He was never there with us when we had to do logistics stuff.
So
that's,
I guess that's expected.
Now we're going
back to the book the next morning,
Travis and his teammates are woke around 5:30 AM to a huge explosion.
A few minutes later,
they learned that observation post Baghdad,
a new makeshift based they had been working to set up in Fallujah was a pile of
rubble.
Okay.
They go to that location with gunfire initially surrounding them before a secure
perimeter was established.
Travis Elvino my saying that right,
I'll be not al albino and others spent the next eight hours and ring and
reentering the rubble while their team members controlled the crowd outside for
all they knew,
the rest of the bombed out complex could have crumbled or there could've been
other bombs,
tide time to go off.
When the quick reaction force arrived,
they went into the ruins anyway,
carrying a large flashlight,
Travis crawled into the rubble sweating profusely due to the heat,
which is exam exacerbated by small fires burning throughout the compound.
Travis dug through dirt,
sand and remnants of brick searching for trapped Iraqis.
Travis,
I'll be new and their teammates recovered too.
Injured Iraqis and two dead bodies from the attack side.
They're selfless actions had an enduring impact on many of the Iraqis who bore
witness.
So you know,
this is even in America when there's something,
when a bomb,
when a,
when a building is collapsing,
they don't,
you know,
it's really,
really risky to go in there and Travis was like,
no,
we're going in.
There might be survivors,
Iraqi civilians.
He has no idea or maybe they were military guys.
He has no idea.
He didn't know them.
He's going to risk his life to go and help them.
Back to the book.
Less than 24 hours later,
Travis,
his ears were ringing after an IED blew up underneath his vehicle.
The blast,
jarring pounding force loudly and abruptly halted his vehicles patrol through
the city's volatile eastern industrial sector.
Travis had encountered during his first deployment and as recently as nine days
earlier after ensuring that fellow Americans and Iraqis were uninjured.
Travis looked down at the sandy street where the crude explosive device was
buried.
See that wire Travis said to another Iraqi lieutenant,
that's a command wire and it's stretching towards that building.
Gather your men and follow me.
He said to the Iraqi before turning to his marines,
you and the other guys cover us just in case there are snipers.
Lieutenant,
why don't we just leave the Iraqi said to Travis,
because they'll keep planting bombs around here in Kilmore of my men,
more of your men and probably kill some kids.
Travis said,
so respectfully,
lieutenant,
I'm going over there to find out who's responsible with or without you.
After a brief pause,
the Iraqi lieutenant got three of his men and followed Travis as he traced the
command wires,
origin,
rounding a corner,
Travis saw man in civilian clothes,
kneeling over what appeared to be a pile of grenades,
which along with the attach wires appeared to be some sort of booby trap.
Without hesitation,
Travis squared up to confront the threat.
The marines out on the street heard the pop of Travis m two o three grenade
launcher and the subsequent explosion.
Several ran toward the sound while other stayed to keep watch over the exterior.
The tall,
sweaty and surgeon took off running.
Now being chased by a fearless,
determined marine.
Travis had the,
a bad guy in his sights and he wasn't going to let him get away.
Stop.
Travis shouted an Arabic while pursuing this suspect.
By the time the U S and Iraqi reinforcements arrived,
Travis was dragging the frightened suspect down off a wall.
He had tried to scale and an unsuccessful attempt,
unsuccessful attempt to escape after body slamming him to the ground.
Travis put the insurgence,
hands behind his back,
then made sure he was taken in for questioning.
The suspect eventually led the Mitt team to a room not far from the booby trap,
which contained grenades and many more bomb making materials without losing any
lives or ruffling more feathers in the Sunni enclave,
Travis had helped remove Ganley weapons and another terrorist from Falucia
streets.
Yeah.
So,
um,
when I heard that story,
what do was share with me?
One of the other parts of it is that when Travis ended up catching this guy,
put a,
I guess a good rest of them move on,
put him down to ground,
uh,
the Iraqis actually wanting to take this guy out,
you know,
and that he's like,
no,
you're not doing that.
We're taking them back,
you know,
and uh,
they figured we'll just take care of this guy right here right now.
Yeah.
And they just,
he just got,
Travis got,
just got hit with an Iud.
And by the way,
it must have gone low order,
which means it must not have detonated properly because if you're in a Humvee
and you can hit with a legitimate IED,
it hits your vehicle under your vehicle,
your chances of Bible isn't great.
And,
and so to have this guy actually hit you with an ID that you're lucky enough to
survive and then you catch him
and then,
you know,
I bet you that,
I wonder,
we could,
I wish we could find out if the,
if the Iraqis that saw this,
if we could find out what wrestling move here used to put the city surgeon on
his back.
They get suplex.
Yeah,
he had a good headlock.
Oh
yeah.
I bet that was not a happy in surgeon at that point.
But you know this also the other thing that was good,
good about this as it,
it shows you how Travis had to lead from the front because like I said,
the Iraqis are just content to say,
hey,
let's just go back to base.
You know,
let's just leave that,
that's very common for them.
And Travis has to lead from the front,
has to say,
no,
we're going to stay.
You can stay here,
but I'm going to go get these guys and you know,
kind of shamed them in to help him now.
Yeah.
You know,
in,
he was doing that,
but he was also seeing it.
The result of that was progress.
Yeah.
But these guys were starting to take on more and more.
And that was important to them.
Even just the fact that they followed him and you know,
that's,
that's what they're doing.
And then what they do is they gain confidence and they say,
yeah,
you know,
we can do this too.
And,
and that's how you eventually turned over battlespace to him.
Yeah.
Going back to the book,
half a world away in California,
Brendan was about to embark on is most difficult child challenged since nine 11
buds training.
Okay.
So,
you know,
I just wanted to point out that while Travis is now back in Fallujah,
Brendan has got his orders and he shows up at buds and you know,
he trained super hard to get ready for it.
And,
and there we go.
While helping turn the tide in Fallujah.
First Lieutenant Travis Manion wrote a letter to the intelligence or one of his
hometown newspapers in Bucks County,
Pennsylvania.
And here's that letter.
There are many views on our mission here.
However,
all I can say with certainty is that there are thousands of Americans over here
working hard towards a positive outcome and Iraq.
Okay.
Every day I'm here,
I see great things being accomplished under harsh circumstances from young
Americans.
I'm truly honored to serve B side,
these marines,
sailors,
soldiers,
and airmen.
I'm not sure the average American sees the positives these service men and women
accomplish or even understands the sacrifices of their efforts.
However,
whatever course of action our leadership decides upon there are those in
waiting,
ready to carry out the mission in support of our country and in defense of its
people and their freedoms.
Respectfully,
Travis Mannion,
First Lieutenant United States Marine Corps.
Yeah,
that sums sums it up totally for him.
I mean,
you always knew where Travis was coming from.
Very straightforward and,
and I mean obviously I agree with them.
That's,
that's all.
A lot of people don't understand it and still don't.
A lot of people still don't understand the,
the positive things that were occurring over in Iraq.
The positive things that the simple,
having lunch with them,
the simple trying to prevent collateral damage.
You know,
that's been mentioned several times.
that the Iraqi soldiers,
they get content,
somebody shoots at them,
they shoot in 360 degrees,
they don't care where it hits and they're doing everything they can to train
them and,
and put some discipline on them so that they don't hurt those civilians.
So,
and the willingness,
you know,
you guys tell us what to do,
you guys give us,
give us the mission and we're standing here and we'll get it accomplished.
So now they're looking at up,
uh,
a mission in an area of Fallujah,
which is called the pizza slice.
And if you go look at a map of Fallujah,
it's really obvious to figure out where the pizza slices I did.
I did actually did one operation,
my first deployment to Iraq to in the pizza slice.
And they're looking at doing an operation there.
They got some intelligence that there's a bad guy there that they want to go and
get.
And we're going back to the book.
After discussing the idea with several fellow officers,
including Travis Major Qubica,
I say that right?
It could.
Vicky.
Yeah.
Major Kabuki announced that a team would head into the pizza slice to follow up
on new intelligence about the snipers whereabouts.
So it's a sniper that they're going after an enemy's sniper.
Hopefully they could find the terrorist sniper who was shooting at US marines,
Iraqi soldiers and civilians to American Humvees would accompany to full
vehicles of Iraqi army troops in one home.
V would be Kabuki,
Albinos,
and Kim.
They would be joined by the driver,
Staff Sergeant Paul Petty and the Turret Gunner,
Staff Sergeant Josh Wilson,
Marangu and Segall seagull,
Marangu and seagull seagull,
Chuck Segal,
merengue and Siegel would ride in the second home.
V,
the driver would be staff sergeant Chad Marquette,
Turret gunner,
corporal briner and Mohammed and Iraqi interpreter Travis and second Lieutenant
Scott Alexander,
a friend and fellow Mitt team member.
We're supposed to go to a nearby school with Iraqi soldiers and hand out candy,
crayons and coloring books to local kits.
Travis who was excited about the mission because he cared about the Iraqis and
love to see the smiles on the faces of the kids.
So they got two operations that they're about to execute.
One of them is to go and hunt down the sniper and the other one is to go do some
build.
Some wins,
some hearts and minds handing out candy to the kids.
Okay,
now,
Kim is one of the other Mitt team officers.
He's the ops.
Oh,
the ops officer.
That's,
that's your cam is,
and we're going back to the book Kim,
who had smelled ugliness in the air when he woke up that morning and had
reiterated,
reiterated his uneasiness just minutes earlier,
told Travis at the smiles of Iraqi school,
children will be a welcome sight.
Kim was a brave marine who repeatedly distinguished himself on the battlefield,
but on this day he felt worn down.
Fortunately,
he and Travis were close enough that he felt confident asking his friend to take
his place on major Qubica cheese pizza slice patrol team.
Is it cool if I had over to the school instead?
Kim asked,
no problem.
Travis replied his eyes lighting up because he knew this meant he could help go
find the sniper.
Are you sure?
Kevin's sistered go ahead with Scott to the school.
Travis said,
we're all good.
Thanks Travis.
Kim said,
I'll see you in a bit.
See you back here.
Travis said with a nod.
Yes.
So I'm never knew that story.
And when we're writing the book,
start to talk to Chris about that day and you know,
he said,
hey,
I've got something I want to share.
Did I never has shared before.
And you mentioned that,
you know,
we're supposed to be me on that patrol magic w would take for him to sort of
come forward that story.
But he and in,
uh,
Travis and Scott were really close and I know it had to be bothering him for a
while and he,
he shared that.
So,
so they roll into the pizza slice,
which again,
this is
just to do,
it's a picture in your mind,
what it looks like.
It's you kind of your stereotypical combat Iraq city,
small,
narrow streets,
you know,
trash in the streets,
buildings really close together.
Threats everywhere.
Dirty rundown wires everywhere.
It's just a,
it's kind of your stereotypical Iraqi combat city.
That's exactly what it,
what it is in the pizza slice and Falucia there in their perimeter and boom.
Here we go to the book.
The enemy sniper pulled the trigger blasting what felt like a metal pipe
throughout binos lower left album,
abdomen,
the bullet which ricocheted off the Corman's radio then tore through his left
lung.
How Beano fell to his knees,
dropping his weapon and landing flat on his face in the sword.
Trash filled streets.
Mother fucker yelled petty,
who had gotten a thumbs up from the dock.
A split second before in an instant,
Travis and cubic,
he started running toward the wounded.
Korman casualty screamed the court,
the Turret gunner of the other American home.
V He was the only one in the vehicle that to see our Beano go down.
Everyone in the Humvee froze Iraqi.
A Stone Marangu yelled out in response despite the sudden jolt of adrenaline
there.
Heart sank when they heard the gunners response,
it's doc,
he yelled,
opening fire ambush.
Travis reacted as soon as the first shot rang out.
He took off running toward us.
Wounded comrade as the thunder sound of American Turk.
Gunfire ring out in the once quiet alleyway,
even with the enemy shooting above from above.
Travis didn't care about his own safety.
He knew he this could be his only chance to save doc
at the other American home.
V Marangu and Segal also took off in albinos direction.
Though V,
we're trained to never run towards a sniper's victim.
The warrior ethos of never leaving a fallen comrade behind had overwritten their
sensibilities.
Travis,
her reached doc first,
grabbed him by the left shoulder and cubic III who was running close behind
clutched albinos right arm.
A few seconds later,
come on,
doc.
Travis yelled as he,
as he and the major polled albino close to the Humvee bullets were now raining
down from multiple rooftops,
which meant that more insurgents had been waiting with the sniper to ambush the
American Iraqi and Iraqi troops.
The Mitt team was encircled by insurgents and without a fierce counter attack,
the entire patrol was almost certainly doomed.
As bedlam ensued,
the Marines realized that both Iraqi vehicles in their patrol were gone.
After the Iraqi soldiers heard the gunfire.
The front vehicle subsequently hit an IED while trying to loop around towards a
better fighting position.
The Iraqi's were stranded,
which meant nine Americans and their interpreter were left outnumbered in a
confined,
chaotic space.
Yeah.
So,
um,
you know,
with Travis that day,
he,
he helped pull doc and doc said,
when I went to see dock at the Bethesda hospital,
he said,
you know,
I just felt this,
this big hand,
come in and grab me and pull me in.
And they were surrounded there and,
and um,
you know,
was,
uh,
the sniper was there firing away.
Um,
I don't know if you're going to share,
but chuck Siegel was also wounded.
Yup.
As he,
he came actually got an email from chuck recently just to,
you know,
so many years later just to sort of talk about that day and what it was all
about.
But you can imagine that the uh,
the cloud of war chaos,
confusion,
nobody really knows what's going on is I talked to the guys that were there that
day.
Nobody was really sure where things were coming from.
They just knew they were in big trouble.
Yeah.
That's one of the hardest things about the urban environment.
It happens in all environments,
but in the urban environment,
you hear shots coming in,
you don't know where they're coming from.
It's very difficult to tell because the sound reflects and refracts off the
different buildings and you know,
the sniper or the,
the shooters can be one or two rooms deep.
You did,
you just don't know where the,
where the,
where the rounds are coming from and it's just very,
very confusing.
Lot of confusion from,
from all the guys I spoke with.
Okay.
Going back to the book here,
Travis and cubic.
He dragged lb no out of the kill zone and closer to the vehicles front side
where the sniper couldn't deliver a fatal blow to their bleeding,
gasping Korman as they tended to albinos wounds.
Travis saw Marangu and Segal running toward him at full speed.
Another Pearson crack of gunfire abruptly echoed through the alley.
It an instant Siegel was somersaulting in midair,
feeling like Mike Tyson had just punched him in the stomach and landing in the
middle of the bullet riddled street all around Segal who broke his law rifle
wall collapsing the ground,
uh,
hectic battle was unfolding in an eerie,
slow motion.
Silence,
seagulls wrist convulsed with tremendous pain.
The sniper was firing at the wounded marine as he lay in the street.
And the young lance corporal who had just been shot in the wrist and still
unbeknownst to him also in the stomach,
would soon be dead if he didn't get in front of that Humvee as seagull.
Late powerless,
unable to do anything but wait for the crushing blow of another sniper bullet.
Travis pulled him out of the snipers crosshairs.
Moments later,
Segal lay next to Al [inaudible] who is still being worked on by cubic
[inaudible].
So again,
you know,
if you got a sniper scenario and there's a guy down,
the last thing you want to do is run over to try and help get him out of that
situation.
Unless you're Travis and then that's the first thing you're going to do.
Okay?
By the time the confused Lance corporal looked up into the dust,
Travis was gone.
He had already run back into a cloud of bullets.
Travis dashed across the street not far from where Segal had been hit twice,
and merengue had barely escaped death without blinking.
He blasts or grenade onto one of the of buildings sending chunks of concrete
tumbling to the ground.
When Travis switched to m four rounds,
his suppressing fire was equally relentless,
which gave Ku Biki and Marangu enough time to help the wounded with one rooftop
silent after stunned and surgeons had experienced the crushing power of Travis's
grenades and countless and four rounds,
the battles tide begin to turn Siegel and Alby.
No,
couldn't see Travis firing,
but they could hear the welcome sounds of the American counter attack,
which only pause when Travis needed to reload
go.
Travis scream to his fellow officers who moved into new positions so they could
join him in the fire in firing at the enemy.
Travis moving east in the alleyway from the Humvees passenger side to the
driver's side,
is he blast away at another rooftop was now causing the same kind of pandemonium
among the enemy that the sniper initially wrought on the Americans just in front
of Seagull.
The corpsman initially pulled to safety by Travis at cubic.
He dragged himself almost completely under the vehicle with only his leg
sticking out,
desperately trying to breathe while tasting a mixture of sand and his own blood.
Albinos.
Almost certain he was going to die
amid dizziness,
extreme thirst and the crashing sounds of concrete.
The wounded Corman pictured his mother whom he didn't want to suffer in the wake
of his death,
but at the same time I'll be no could see Travis boots.
Travis Travis's boots firmly planted in the sand while he fired it.
Enemy positions.
The situation was bleak,
but maybe there was still a chance to survive.
So you got Travis,
it's interesting.
They use the word counter attack and usually when you think of a counter attack,
you think of a platoon,
or at least a squad that's maneuvering to counter attack an enemy.
And in this situation we got a one man counter attack.
That's,
that's the initiative is Travis stepping up,
putting down suppressive fire,
putting down grenade fire.
You're supposed himself to the enemy to make that happen.
Well,
trying to build the momentum the other way because the momentum is coming in so,
so much.
So on the other side that you got to sort of get out and get it on them.
Get the rounds on them.
Yeah.
To have them,
you know,
lose that momentum.
Yeah.
And,
and just like any military unit,
the insurgents,
if they have the upper hand,
they're going to press.
But the minute you can press them back and you get the upper hand,
the chances are they're gonna,
they're gonna retreat because they don't,
they're not holding the ground.
They don't care if they lose ground,
they'll run away.
They want to live.
They're cowards and so they,
they'll,
they'll back away.
But you know,
if you don't do that,
if you don't step up and you don't take the initiative,
they will absolutely override the overrun you.
And so one man counter attack here and then,
and then he's yelling to his teammates,
hey,
go help out.
Let's go.
Let's make this happen.
Back to the book.
Although the sniper would usually have been long gone by now,
the AK 47 fire from other buildings cost so much initial confusion that the Mitt
team still wasn't sure which building he had fired from like a vulture circling
his prey.
The enemy marksman continued scanning the alley before spotting Travis who's
firing away on another rooftop.
So this is a cover and move situation to where the snipers taking precision
shots,
but the guys can't really identify because they're getting shot at from a bunch
of different locations as well.
Okay.
Back to the book across the city.
First Lieutenant Kim was handing Kranz to smiling Iraqi kids with Second
Lieutenant Alexander though Kim wondered how Travis and the guys were fairing
inside the pizza slice.
They'd been through so many battles in the last five months without a casualty
that the Mitt team seemed indestructible.
As Kim knelt with a happy child,
he suddenly heard unintelligible screaming from the radio inside his vehicle.
Contact yelled a voice,
possibly staff Sergeant Perry,
the driver of the Hum v Cam was originally supposed to be in Kim.
Look straight at Alexander who had heard the same frantic sounds and both men
motion to their Iraqi counterparts to sit with the kids while they check things
out.
The transmissions,
the transmissions were broken,
but now the sound of Petty's voice screaming contact came through clear crystal
clear about saying a single word about what to do next.
Kim and Alexander jumped into separate vehicles with their respective drivers,
told the Iraqis to handle the rest of the school supply drop and sped towards
the,
toward the pizza slice and it's unknown turmoil
as they listened to broken radio transmission to try to communicate with Perry
who was frantically trying to contact camp collusion.
Request a quick reaction force.
The Marines silently navigated through the pizza slices.
Narrow,
confusing streets,
not completely sure of where their Mitt team brothers were pinned down.
They knew a battle was raging,
but neither marine had any idea how serious it was nor did they realize Albina
and Siegel had been hit.
After looping around the pizza slice,
the two vehicles turned right onto route Elizabeth near the blackwater bridge
heading east and the seriousness of the situation.
Slapped Cam and Alexander in the face normally bust,
bustling packed marketplace was completely empty if tumbleweeds blowing across
the street.
This section of Felicia would've looked exactly like a deserted town in an old
western spaghetti.
Jesus Christ.
Alexander said,
where the fuck are they came,
yelled and frustration.
Suddenly they heard gunfire there.
Alexander said,
pointing at the besieged alleyway where the two American humvees were still
being riddled bullets
as both marine stopped on route,
Elizabeth facing east,
the marines jumped out and ran as quickly as they could.
Ducking rifles,
ducking his rifles continued to crack towards their comrades.
Kim then confronted an image that would stay with him for the rest of his life.
Travis was lying near the back of the driver's side tire of the Humvee.
He had been riding in his eyes wide open,
but glazed over with emptiness.
Kim saw no blood,
but it was obvious that something horrible.
It occurred in that Richard violent alley
for the first time in the entire deployment,
sheer panic seized.
Kim,
as you ran with Alexander up to Kabuki,
who was kneeling by Travis while filing firing is nine millimeter handgun at one
of the buildings.
After running out of rifle ammunition,
Kim asked,
firing his own rifle,
where do you need us to go get the wounded cubic?
He said,
get them out of here.
Who else has hit?
Alexander said Siegel and doc could,
you said before moving to another position to continue firing,
swinging open the passenger side back door for covers.
He fired.
Kim Saw Siegel who had avoided being shot again,
but we're still in great pain lying in the backseat.
Despite being on his back,
he was reaching down to the floor trying to find more ammunition for the Turret
gunner.
His left wrist was bleeding profusely.
The major orders is out.
Kim said,
do you need help?
I can make it.
Sequel said,
you gotta get Lieutenant Mannion.
I think he's dead.
My vehicle's ride over there.
Kim said,
pointing toward route Elizabeth go.
Now that reinforcements had arrived,
the sniper was gone and the insurgents were pulling back.
Segal mustering all his strength exited the Humvee on the passenger side and
hurried to Kim's vehicle where he collapsed in the backseat.
He knew he had been shot in the stomach by this point and wasn't sure if you'd
make it,
but even Segal ran to the intersection.
Even as Siegel ran to the intersection,
the wounded marines.
Thoughts,
we're focused on the unforgettable scene he had just witnessed SQL didn't see
Travis gets shot by the sniper,
but after dragging himself to the driver's side of the vehicle,
the lance corporal were shocked to see the first lieutenant lying face down in
motionless.
His arms stretched toward the curb with his feet facing toward the bullet
riddled vehicle.
When Segal pulled himself towards Travis and asked him where he'd been hit,
he got no response.
He realized Travis were seriously wounded and started feeling underneath his
fellow marines.
Body armor with his left hand despite the hone his own aching wrist.
He found a bullet wound on the left side of Travis has rib cage.
He whispered and Travis is a year.
Hey,
Travis said Segal,
Segal,
who normally would have addressed him as lieutenant or sir,
I'm here for you.
Yeah.
Travis didn't respond
even without realizing that the sniper's bullet had struck the first lieutenant
from the right side and had exited at the spot he was covering with his left
hand.
Siegel knew the situation was grave when sat,
when Travis began jerking with convulsions,
is he dead?
Could Vicki yelled over to Segal while continuing to fire it?
Enemy positions,
not yet,
but he will be if we don't do something.
The lance corporal said his voice shaking
SQL turned to Travis whose eyes were still wide open.
I'm here for you.
Segal repeated over and over again into his ear.
As soon as Kim and Alexander had carry,
they're unresponsive.
Friend into the vehicle could Vicki ran over and dove into the smoke filled
Humvee where he clutched Travis and begin trying to identify as wounds stopping
the bleeding and perform CPR.
He ordered petty to start driving towards Camp Falucia.
While Wilson Wilson fired the last rounds from the Turret.
This was probably could Vicky's last chance to save his fellow marine.
As for vehicles sped toward Camp Falucia,
Father John Gaten,
Marine Corps chaplain from Pennsylvania sat in his tiny office on the mic,
makeshift American base.
He was reading emails from home while sipping from a large water bottle to keep
hydrated on the steam.
You Sunday afternoon.
A few minutes later,
his phone ring,
we got two wounded in action and one possible killed in action.
Arriving at the field hospital,
a nurse,
a nurse reported
as the marines ran over to the wooden complex.
He saw a group of Marines,
Kim Alexander Kubicki,
Marangu Petty Marquette Wilson and briner huddled like a team on a football
field as he jogged by one of them,
turned around and looked at him.
Father John saw the redness in the eyes of this marine who had obviously been
crying.
It was clear that something terrible had happened.
Any marines with type O positive blood report immediately to field hospital room
for a voice said over the loudspeaker.
Okay.
As they tore off.
Yeah.
As they tore off his bloody fatigues before finding the wounds on each side of
his rib cage and trying to resuscitate him,
crowds began to form in the hallway outside the operating room.
Word
was quickly spreading.
That First Lieutenant Travis Mannion,
the heart and soul of the Mitt team
was badly wounded.
Yeah,
he's a
gave it all,
you know,
gave it all that day.
He gave it all,
every moment he was over there and working with the marines,
working with the Iraqis and,
and um,
you know,
that that last event
he ran out of Ammo,
you know,
I was talking to the gunner
and
start to ask him about what,
what he saw trying to figure out,
you know,
the,
we've got what was written up in his award and just trying to get some insights.
And the gunner said,
you know,
lieutenant was calling for more ammo.
So I'm thinking that Travis,
I saw when he was over there,
he had all sorts of magazines.
So I don't know how many rounds would,
I'm guessing around maybe 90 to 100 rounds.
He had one himself and he'd actually laid down a lot of fire to change the
momentum.
But I,
you know,
he knew what he was doing.
He exposed himself.
He had to do that to get out there and lay down the fire.
And,
uh,
when I spoke to the Gunner Wilson,
he said,
you know,
we threw out a magazine.
I turned around when I turned back,
Travis was laying on the ground,
so maybe he was trying to get that magazine and load it into his weapon.
He had,
he'd run out all of his ammunition in lane cover for these guys.
Yeah,
no.
And like you said,
I mean,
just somebody had to turn the momentum.
Yeah.
Otherwise they were going to get overrun.
And he knew that.
He knew that,
if not me,
than who,
you know,
he knew what he had to do.
I know that.
Um,
cause they had lost,
they had,
I got a letter from [inaudible] shortly afterwards and he said,
you know,
we're using Travis,
his words to go on because he,
they had lost some guys and he had pulled the team and said,
look,
we got gotta they'd want us to go on,
we've got to keep working,
we've got to turn the tide here.
And so he used that session that Travis had with the team and said,
look,
you know what Travis would think,
you know what we gotta do?
We gotta keep fighting on.
And that's what they did.
Okay.
Father John Anointed Travis,
his feet instead of prayer,
has the medical staff tried fevers,
Lee to revive him?
If only the marine could the doctors
some sign
any sign of life
soon after the physician in charge announced a time of death.
Yeah,
for the next minute.
The only sounds heard in the operating room came from the hallway outside
as doctors and nurses watched in silence.
Father John Standing above the following us marine broke the silence.
Okay
God,
the father of mercies.
Through the death and resurrection of your son.
You have reconciled the world to yourself and sent the Holy Spirit among us for
the forgiveness of sins.
He said,
looking down at Travis
through the Ministry of the church,
may God grant you pardon and peace
and I absolve you of your sins in the name of the father,
kind of the sun
and of the Holy Spirit.
Yeah.
One by one marines filed past their fallen brother.
Could Vicky,
the senior officer would desperately administered CPR in the Humvee was the
first to walk by Moran was next.
Then Wilson,
Marquette and briner.
When petty looked at the fallen first lieutenants face,
he saw an officer who had given everything to the Marine Corps.
When Alexander approached the operating table with tears streaming down his
face,
he put his hand on his friend's head.
He didn't know how the mission could carry on without them
came approached the table with weak knees and a broken heart.
He paused to take one last look at his friend who had saved his life by
volunteering to go on a patrol he knew would be far more dangerous than a school
supply drop.
Pausing for a moment,
Kim pondered the story that was already spreading throughout the hospital
complex.
Without thinking twice,
Travis had leapt squarely into enemy crosshairs to direct gun fire away from his
patrol.
On April 29th,
2007,
a line of the Iraq war was struck down by a single bullet.
Okay.
Cut through Travis aorta causing massive internal bleeding that couldn't be
controlled
though the fallen marines loved ones would undoubtedly suffer.
Everyone else on the pizza slice patrol was still alive
indeed by fearlessly protecting his marines and the Iraqi serving beside them.
First Lieutenant Travis men had done his part.
Yeah.
So clearly in,
in writing,
this is sorta
as a father obviously really tough to to go through and,
and you know,
talk to the guys who were with him and relive that.
Okay.
Uh,
but the other side of it is,
it's a little healing.
Did this sorta know exactly what was going on and what the guys that were there
with him,
he felt about his actions that day.
Okay.
And so,
um,
you know,
as I went through a struggle at times,
but I realized that,
um,
you know,
unless we tell these stories,
the rest of the country's not going to know what these guys are doing.
So we got to make sure that we get the word out there.
And there was a big part of it is,
is sitting down and talking through that day big part of uh,
the struggle for me and putting this book together.
And you just,
I mean it's,
it's uh,
I would say it's a miracle that everyone else lived,
but it's actually just Travis that everyone lived in a situation like that
surrounded by enemy,
a sniper,
multiple enemy positions firing on you.
You got nine guys in to hundred.
These,
that is not a good situation to be in and it's going to take a miracle to get
out of it.
And the fact that he's the only guy that was killed is incredible.
And it's clearly,
you know,
due to his actions.
Okay.
Clearly,
I mean,
again,
you have the enemy has elevated positions to on the rooftops and yeah.
So yeah,
I mean it's important obviously to tell the story and people to know the
sacrifice.
And I mean a lot of,
a lot of people listen to this that are active duty in the military and that
sort of aggressiveness on the battlefield when things are going bad is going to
keep people alive.
And obviously you got to be a courageous,
courageous human being to do that.
But the alternative,
you know,
in this case would have been an incredibly horrible,
I got it.
Um,
several of the guys were there,
whether it was the doc when I went to see him at Bethesda,
talked about the impact of what Travis or Lieutenant Marangu was there.
And he sent me a message and said,
hey,
you know,
there's no doubt in my mind that Travis saved my life and the life of the entire
patrol that day.
So,
I mean the guys that were there were with them.
They know what I'm,
yeah.
Okay.
In how much longer after this did you start writing this book?
Wow.
About five years afterwards.
Just start to get down to writing it and I,
you know,
there's a story behind that too,
right?
I mean I,
uh,
the last time I talked to Travis was a week before we lost him and it was an
unusual call because normally I was with my wife and this time I wasn't Isabel
by myself and he,
I guess he fell a little bit more open to share with me what was going on.
And he was,
you could sense that there was a lot happening.
And he had a message for me,
kept sharing that.
He said,
dad,
it's incredible what I'm seeing over here.
It's incredible what these young marines are doing.
What I'm seeing every day they're fighting in the streets,
they're putting it on the line.
I don't think the rest of the country knows what's going on.
And he knew that cause you go back to Camp Fallujah,
turn on the TV and see what we were watching back here and then he'd be on
patrol and just sort of see the incredible things that were going on and it was
a huge disconnect for him.
And he got cut off several times in that phone call and he kept calling me back
and he'd start all over again.
Dad,
you,
you really,
he really got to get the message back to people.
It's incredible what's happening here.
You know the American people don't know the incredible things these guys are
doing and so I got cut off for them the last time and I always signed off to
tell him how much they loved them and it was the first time that I missed him.
I figured,
okay,
I'll hear from him next weekend and we got to knock on the door.
Then next weekend that we lost Travis,
you know,
your worst nightmare,
your only son.
So proud of them and figured,
okay,
most natural thing for us is to roll down the shades,
lock the doors,
and just tell everyone to go away.
And it was because that last conversation I had with him,
we knew there was going to be media and sure enough there was pull my wife and
daughter together.
I said,
you know what?
When they call us,
we're going to talk.
And really this book is about talking about sharing the stories.
I've been on that mission since the last time I talked to Travis and he gave me
that mission to do this.
And so I was pretty certain early on that was going to do something.
Initially I thought,
okay,
I heard about Travis and his marines and inclusion and how they turned the tie.
So maybe that that would be the story.
We could talk about how these brave marines and work together with the Iraqis to
make that happen.
And then we lost Brendan,
you know,
and I realized,
maybe it's not that story.
Maybe it's the bigger story of our navy seals and our marines and everyone that
it's putting on the uniform and the sacrifices they're making.
And so,
um,
that's why it sort of took me a little while.
I mean,
we had,
we lost Travisano seven,
we lost Brendan in 2010 when,
and I had just come back from,
from doing some of the stuff over in Iraq started to think,
well maybe it's a different story and a,
when you do a really,
you know,
an amazing job in the book of talking about how you,
how your family,
how you've,
you and your family,
you know,
dealt with the loss and,
but is there anything that you find,
I mean,
did you find it to be sort of therapeutic to say,
look,
we have a new mission now.
Our mission is to get the word out and tell the story and learn as much as we
can about it and let other people know what's going on.
I think it was,
it definitely helped,
you know,
to know that we could do something with his loss,
get out there and if we could do something to,
to bridge the gap between the country and our military and our guys and men and
women serving in uniform,
you know,
certainly gave us something to get up every morning and,
and have a reason.
And now when we start thinking about his message,
you know,
part of that,
if not me,
then who message that goes back to that last conversation I had with him because
when we started telling the stories,
my son in law shared that story with the newspaper and all of a sudden that,
if not me,
then who is sort of caught on and people started to say,
you know what?
I like that it was five simple but really,
really powerful words.
And that's what we use now as our sort of rally cry for our foundation if not
me.
The new
you,
you went through this,
you know,
you went through your loss of Travis and did you get closer with,
with Brendan after that or did it maintain or,
yeah,
we got a lot closer with Brendan.
I mean,
absolutely.
Uh,
Brandon was in seal training when we lost Travis,
and I still remember that call with,
with my wife.
Uh,
but yeah,
he would come and,
and visit us.
And,
and uh,
still remember when he came back and he came right up to our place and mostly
people felt uncomfortable coming to,
to visit the parents by themselves.
So they'd come in groups.
But when Brendan called up shortly after he got back and I said,
okay,
well you come out with brand new,
says I'm coming by myself.
And we spent the night doing shots patroned at our bar and talking about stories
of he and Travis and their friendship.
And
what was it?
Uh,
another thing was Travis or,
or Brendan had just started buds.
Yeah.
And you know,
he was saying,
Hey,
I'm going to come home for the funeral.
And,
and you and your wife said,
no,
you do what you gotta do.
You gotta get through this training.
You know,
you can come later.
Yeah.
Which is,
well,
we,
we knew he was just sort of struggling with the loss in a big,
big way.
Any,
any wanted to,
to be there.
And,
you know,
he was sharing that with my wife real strong.
And,
uh,
you know,
he knew what Travis would want them to do is the carry on and,
and so we did that,
you know,
and he,
he,
he sure did that in a,
in a big way out there in San Diego.
Yeah.
And Brendan crushed crushed buds.
And you don't throw that around.
Bitely you don't throw around.
Some will crushing Bud's lightly.
Uh,
and one of the things,
one of the quotes that they pull out in here that he applied during buds was one
of,
one of Brendan's favorite quotes was one,
he rarely spoke out loud,
but always kept in the back of his mind.
Be Strong,
be accountable,
never complain.
Yeah,
that's Brandon.
Absolutely.
And that attitude going in.
He ended up being the honor man of his buds class.
And so the honor man is the guy that's basically the best performer in
everything.
And again,
you're going to buds,
you got some competitive high level athletes in there and to be the honor man,
you gotta be a bit of a bad ass.
Yeah.
Well some of the guys were there with him share with me that it wasn't even
close even,
you know,
I mean like he was blowing everything away.
So he was,
he was possessed as they,
they share with me.
That's a,
that sounds like,
that sounds like he was definitely getting after it.
And,
and,
you know,
I,
I won't even say,
I imagine,
I actually know for a fact that Louise and Travis must've fueled his fire beyond
anyone.
Could be.
He probably had,
you're right,
there was no co who's going to compete with that.
You know,
he knew he had a job to do.
And so much so that when,
um,
when he got done and graduated and my wife Janet and I were at the wedding with
Amy and Brendan did,
he called Janet over and gave Janet is navy seal trident
and you know,
he just did it privately.
It was just the way Brandon was gave it to her and said,
you know,
I couldn't have gotten this without Travis being there with me every step of the
way and I want you to have this.
And I was at the other end of the the room and I still remember Jenny coming up
with tears in her eyes and sharing this story with me.
It was just sort of the type of Guy Brandon was,
you know.
Yeah.
I mean that was another thing that they,
that in the book you talk about is he got the honor man plaque it and like he
like mailed it to his parents and his attitude was,
hey,
this is an Ami,
you know,
this is on you.
Thanks for support over the years.
Yeah.
And then give them the trident to,
to your wife,
Janet.
I mean,
just a humble,
humble guy that always gave credit to everyone else.
And,
and your wife gave him the black bracelet
that said,
first Lieutenant Travis Mandian USFC spartan hero leader
killed them.
Iraq,
Iraqi Freedom.
29 April of Oh seven.
And then this had to be hard for you can now you're even closer with Brandon,
with,
with Brendan.
You're even closer with Brendan and
he tells you guys at his wedding.
So you're,
they're celebrating the wedding and all of a sudden he says something to tell
you go to Iraq and 48 hours.
Yeah.
It was a,
and by the way,
it's going to Falucia did he tell you guys he was going to Fallujah?
Yeah,
he told us where he was headed.
Um,
you know,
hard to believe,
he's there celebrating such a great day and then to find out that his honeymoons
in Fallujah,
you know,
I think in,
you hear about,
we hear so much about our guys in uniform and what they're doing,
but just sort of think about this,
those types of sacrifices,
you know,
we don't hear enough of that stuff.
You know,
what the families are going through and missing those special times.
it's a
big,
big impact all the way around.
Well,
I always try and remind people that the,
the heroes that we talk about their heroes and they're people,
they're people like everyone else with wives and families and they miss their,
their home.
They miss their family.
They want to be at the dance recital and the basketball game and the wrestling
match.
They're not just these,
you know,
foreign objects that just do nothing but fight man.
They're people.
And I always try and remind,
remind everyone of that,
and this is a classic example here he is married his sweetheart who had met at
the Naval Academy.
Yeah.
Spending time with you.
Spending time with his family and he's leaving for Iraq 48 hours later.
Honeymoon and [inaudible]
yeah.
Big,
big sacrifice for these guys.
And he does that deployment to Fallujah and
um,
kind of,
you know,
here's,
here's a letter that he wrote home on that ms man.
Yeah.
And it was great seeing you guys at the wedding.
I'm glad you guys able to make it meant a lot to both me and Amy to see you both
there.
I'm doing okay over here.
Since since arriving,
I've been tasked with reviewing all the evils.
It's evaluation and awards for the command as well as work in the tactical
operations center.
I'm sure you've heard about the decreased violence out here and provincial Iraqi
control taking place in our long bar to see how much different it is over here.
Since last time is a true testament to the work that everyone over here has
done.
I've not had the opportunity to get out to combat outposts Mannion on a trip out
west to al-Assad while myself and Rob Sarver,
another U U S Naval Academy Oh four guy who knew Travis.
We're waiting for our Hilo to show up.
We struck up a conversation with a young lance corporal.
This young marine was a Mitt team member and had mentioned that he'd just come
from cop Mannion.
When we heard that,
I let them know that Travis was a good friend of mine and a college and a
roommate during college.
He said that he did not know him,
but he'd heard great things about Travis.
He also said that there was a room at the cop dedicated to him with pictures.
I just thought you would like that story since Travis is still influencing the
men and women over here.
Love Brendan.
Yeah,
he eventually made it out there.
Rob shared with me,
but oh,
he made it out to cop.
Mannion was caught and in Fallujah or was it another session?
It was north.
The Karma.
Okay.
If you've ever been through Karma,
I didn't go through Karma.
Karma is when I was over there.
They flew me out to camp solution.
Then a Karma is not too far away from Camp Fallujah and it's little,
little north of Karma.
So the Iraqis,
um,
said they wanted the name the outpost after Travis,
which was,
you know,
again for the recognition of what he put on the line for them.
Yeah.
Awesome.
So,
but you could see from,
from that note that what Brendan was facing in,
in Felucia at that time,
even over what it would have been a six month period or,
or something maybe longer than that,
but it was completely mellow compared to what Travis wasn't during.
You know,
we were just way ahead at that time.
Yeah.
It changed dramatically at that point for sure.
And so Brendan had a fairly mellow deployment,
comes home and then goes back on deployment.
You know,
again,
like you just said,
new wife,
you just went on deployment.
Doesn't matter where sending you back in on deployment.
That's the way it works.
Two,
three,
four deployments.
Yup.
Yeah.
So now we're talking,
he goes back this time it goes to Afghanistan.
It'll,
you know,
just a little bit about,
about Brendan's leadership with the Taliban launching its annual spring
offensive.
Brendan and his platoon started to see more action in May,
just as he had predicted in his email to Tom and Janet surrounded jagged cliffs,
extreme pop property and acute desolation,
which many of the younger seals had never experienced.
It was Brendan's responsibility to keep them optimistic,
focused and sharp,
considering that the seals were sleeping on a fob in the middle of nowhere,
thousands of miles away from home.
Setting a positive tone was never an easy task,
rather than barking out orders to the seals under his command.
Brendan was loomed dog,
the unlisted seals as they loved working for the 29 year old lieutenant because
even though Brendan was an officer,
he still thought of himself as one of the boys.
So,
you know,
you see a very similar type of attitude.
Yeah.
He's guys,
you know,
having a chance to talk to them.
They,
you know,
everybody loved Brandon and he's just a great,
great leader,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
no doubt.
Like I said,
the biggest thing I remember about him,
you know,
was no matter what I was saying to him,
not,
not an attitude,
but just like a positive attitude.
I'll say that.
Yeah.
He's getting towards the end of that deployment,
like right towards the end of that deployment and it goes back and forth.
Emails with Amy on Monday,
Amy and Brendan exchanged emails six months that Amy dreaded.
We're coming to a close and finally they would be living together again as
husband and wife.
Brendan could barely contain himself during his last reply before his last
mission.
Can't wait to get home and going along overdue vacation with you or call you
when I get back from my,
I'll love you miss you.
Me,
so they roll out on this operation.
Brendan's assignment in support of operation sea serpent and ongoing joint
anti-terror salt was to watch over the village of [inaudible] in the mountains
and southeastern Afghanistan province of
is that cool?
As on other tactical Overwatch missions on this one,
Brendan and his team would serve as guardian angels much like when Travis held
the roof during after a Corrine attack in Falucia.
No matter what transpired in the darkness below,
Brendan and his seals equipped with night vision equipment would be watching
quiet and focused.
Lieutenant Brendan Looney flew above the skies of Afghanistan on the 59th combat
mission of his fourth overseas deployment.
As bright moonlight shined into the chopper through the war zone soaring
mountains.
The words Spartan hero leader reflected from the Bracelet Brendan always wore on
his right wrist.
Moments from landing on top of a mountain,
the seals and soldiers aboard the chopper on hook their safety belts and prepare
to dismount.
Suddenly a terrible piercing sound stoned everyone to board the helicopter,
which rapidly tumbled down a jagged steep cliff before plunging into the
darkness.
Frantic moments then sued were harrowing,
dreadful and tragic.
So that's Brendan's just think about it is 59th combat mission and he's two
weeks from coming home and the new group comes in.
And who's the one guy that says,
you know what,
I'll go with the new guys and,
and show him around.
I've been at,
we've been out here the whole time.
I don't want them going out there without anyone.
And that's Brendan Looney.
Yeah.
You know,
and he,
he jumps in and,
and a helicopter went down and only one survived.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a turnover operation is what we call it.
That's when you,
you're taking the,
the new guys,
as you said,
I think these guys were from team for taking them out.
You know,
you're just,
you know,
one guy that,
hey,
we've done this before.
We'll just do a turnover and make sure you guys know what's happening and give
you any vice we can.
And like you said,
you're,
you're ready to go home.
Yeah.
And
somebody's got to step up and do that.
Yeah.
And like you said,
who's going to do it?
Well,
Brendan's going to do it.
Yeah.
And you know,
after,
after Brendan was killed and you guys,
you know,
Amy Head had said she wanted Brendan to be buried next to Travis.
Yeah.
You know,
you,
yes.
You wonder why things happen the way they do.
But we never had that talk with Travis.
Like,
what happens if you don't come back?
And when we lost him,
my wife and I were like,
well,
we should have him near us here at home.
So we burned him close by us and outside of Philadelphia.
And then shortly after that we heard from some found me and friends that,
hey,
they had a serious conversation with Travis and he said he wanted to be in
Arlington if anything happened to him.
So I called down to Arlington.
They said,
ah,
yeah,
we can,
we've reentered,
we can do that.
Just let us know if you want that to happen and we'll make it happen.
So,
um,
we never got Travis situated,
never had a headstone,
had a wooden cross there.
And we kept talking about it,
you know,
and it's almost three years later and my wife was the one that was most
reluctant because she was visiting Travis every day and she just couldn't come
to grips with making that decision.
And then we get the call.
The first person that did Brandon's mom called was my wife Janet when she got
the news and we were just devastated.
And we got down there and Amy came into town.
She said,
you know,
I want,
I want Brendan next to Travis and Arlington.
Now she knew she at Travis Service,
she knew Travis wasn't it only to,
but maybe she'd forgotten in the shock.
And I know how that goes.
You're just in total shock.
And um,
at that point I could just see it in my,
my wife's eyes.
She said,
this is it.
This is now we need to do this.
She was ready to do it.
And they move mountains to make it happen.
I mean,
they,
department of the army and Arlington moved,
helped us move Travis down there in two weeks.
And,
um,
and then we laid Brennan that following Monday,
which we originally said,
let's do this the same day.
And I was like,
well,
no,
this is,
this is Brendan's Day would just like a quiet ceremony.
So we did it the Friday before and this quiet ceremony we had,
um,
we had all the marines from,
from Mannion hall down at where the officer's school was.
They have a hall named after Travis.
They all showed up.
And of course the loony.
She,
you think about our service members,
but the strength of the families they were,
they insisted with all that we're going through that they were going to be over
there and they were there with us.
So we laid Travis down on that Friday and then Brendan the following Monday and
secretary gates was there and all his navy seals were there to pay him respects
and they put their tribe and it's in his,
you know,
his coffin.
And it was a real emotional time,
obviously,
and I just like a such a such a tough time.
I'm going to close out the book here with the words that you spoke on the day
that you in turn,
Travis at Arlington.
I want to thank the Loonie family for their presence here today.
Our hearts go out to you as you deal with this incredible loss.
Brendan represents the best this country has to offer.
We mourn him now and we will forever the passing of this American hero.
There are so many mixed emotions for us as we move Travis to this place of
honor.
Brendan's loss fills all our waking hours.
Yet we're moving Travis to be next to his great friend
and together with all their warrior brothers and sisters who've paid their full
measure,
defending freedom.
This solemn place leaves us with a sadness for the sacrifices,
but also extremely proud of these brave Americans who so unselfishly and
courageously stepped forward to confront the evil that faces our world.
We,
the families of these defenders of freedom can't begin to describe the void that
fills our hearts.
But we can tell you how much our sons and daughters love this country and all
that it stands for.
We are now therefore choice.
So Travis,
as we lay you here today,
beside your brother
Brendan
and with all your fellow patriots,
we will always remember,
yeah,
the selfless service and sacrifice.
Okay.
And we will continue to rally in your honor with the call,
if not me,
then who?
To make a difference for others and to always step forward to do what's right no
matter what the cost.
God bless you,
my son,
and rest in peace with your warrior brothers and sisters.
First Lieutenant Travis Mannion,
United States Marine Corps.
We tried to Brendan Looney.
Okay.
United States Navy
warriors for freedom
brothers
forever.
Yeah.
So you,
when you think about section 60 and all the loss there and you know,
symbolically there,
Brendan and Travis,
great friends and they're side by side and Arlington native,
if you're ever there,
you know,
when I'm out talking to people I say,
if you don't,
if you haven't taken your family that Armington put it on the list,
you're in DC or,
or make a special trip to DC to go see Arlington and teach your family about
that sacrifice and make sure you go to section 60 where all those heroes of
today have Iraq and Afghanistan are,
is always something that's just happening in section 60
and after that,
that,
uh,
September when we moved Travis in that following a following spring,
the navy seals found and killed Osama bin Ladin.
And then a couple of weeks later the president spoke about Travis and Brendan as
an example for the country in Arlington and his Memorial Day address.
We were down there with the loonies to hear that.
But again,
their,
their story is a story that could be anybody's story.
There's so many in uniform do so much.
And for me,
writing this book is,
is telling their story but making sure it's part of that bigger story and that
people appreciate our men and when I'm in uniform and all they are and what they
stand for.
Well it's a,
it's an amazing story and Travis is still
doing good right now with his name it and you know,
you guys started the Travis Manion foundation.
Tell us a little bit about that.
Well,
you know,
as I shared earlier,
we wanted to make sure we made an impact him and we got the word out and,
and,
and part of that was my wife said,
you know,
I'm going to start a foundation and I want it to be there for our veterans,
make sure I'm supporting the families of the fallen.
And the last part of it was,
was making sure that we do something to support that next generational leaders.
So she started a character program.
Character does matter where we get veterans in front of young kids and talk
about character and service and integrity and leadership.
And you know,
my wife started that.
We had good friends that were there when we lost Travis.
They said,
you know what,
you guys should set up a memorial fund in lieu of flowers.
And we did that.
And before we knew it,
when we turned around and looked at the bank account,
we had money coming in from all over the country and we had $200,000 my wife had
$200,000 and she had those five words from Travis,
if not me,
than who.
And she got going with that with those two things.
And she came in every day first started right our kitchen and started working
it.
And you know,
she worked at too,
when we lost her,
lost Janet,
five years,
almost five years to the day after Travis with lost my wife to cancer.
And it gets you,
you know,
you think about that,
that sacrifice and the impact on the families.
And I remember doing some research after we found out she had cancer and said as
she had a significant stressful event in the last four to five years.
Yeah.
You know,
she lost her son.
And we think about that.
And then you think about Brendan's mom who recently died of cancer or JP
blacksmiths,
mom who died of cancer,
you know,
so the impact is significant across the board for our families and our,
our guys and gals in uniform.
So we got going on that and,
and my daughter's picked it up since and she's doing a great job with that.
She's working with a lot of,
a lot of great young people.
Amy loonies and other one of the leaders of the foundation and she heads up
operations in Washington DC.
We've got an office here in San Diego.
Uh,
we've got one we just opened up in Atlanta where outside of Philadelphia,
Washington.
We're getting ready to open up an office in Chicago and we've got an in Houston,
Texas.
And we're working with our veterans in and helping them through transition,
working with the families.
And you,
you asked before is this,
was this somewhat telling this story a little bit therapeutic and you know,
doing this foundation and,
and pushing that forward,
was that therapeutic and um,
you know,
we really believe it is,
and we believe,
you know,
he,
there's a grieving period,
but we know that Travis would not want us to keep grieving.
He'd want us to say,
hey,
let's go,
you know,
pick it up and get out there and,
and do something and make a difference.
And so we,
we do that,
you know,
that's what we do every day and we give some of the families chance to do that
too.
We get families that go out and go on expeditions and help those that are in
need build houses and it's really great for them.
You know,
it's great to see them out there doing something and honor the last one,
love one and making an impact for others.
What's the best way for people to support,
where can they find out information about the Travis Manion foundation?
Yeah,
they can go on our website,
Travis Manion.
Dot work.
Okay.
Got a lot of information there were around the country doing different things.
We've got offices in some locations,
but we've got activities almost everywhere.
And um,
for us it's about joining the,
if not me,
then who movement,
you know,
making a difference wherever you can.
And you can do that in a lot of different ways.
That's awesome.
Um,
okay.
Echo.
Speaking of supporting things,
sure.
If someone wanted to support,
let's say for instance,
this podcast,
how would they do that?
Well,
a few weeks.
Let me see.
I'm going to make this one a whole long spiel,
but you know,
we'll start with on it.
That's a good way.
That's a good way to support yourself too,
by the way,
which I think we already know,
but get on it.
These are supplements.
There's other other stuff to work out stuff and whatnot.
But uh,
anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko is 10% off.
Gag on Twitter was asking me.
Oh,
what?
I think he was asking both of us what are like some supplements too?
Gain muscle,
lose fat
burpees.
Yes.
See He will see that answer though.
It wasn't a supplement,
you know,
he was like,
what are the best?
And that's what I thought too.
It's not the supplements,
right.
It's like you got to get on the correct workout,
To do that.
Supplements help though.
And it's going to take certain supplements for whatever results.
So anyway,
to answer that question,
get on a muscle building fat loss workout metcons and I hate to say it,
but like a bodybuilding routine.
You love saying that.
You don't hate to say it.
Yeah.
Well in front of you.
I kind of hate to say it cause the leukemia talking to
see Tom knows.
Yup.
But the supplements will help and like we always say the Krill oil you get on
the Krill oil re cause good.
Yeah.
You know,
so long time ago,
my father in law,
he,
he would always tell my wife though Krill,
it's good for your joints.
It will maintain your and lifting like Krill oil.
Where's the,
you know,
where's a protein powder,
tight attic to even,
actually,
I'd never really was into supplements,
but I was like,
why would I need the Krill oil I'm looking for,
for Gans?
Let's face it.
Exactly right.
You know,
I mean,
respect.
I'm the Krill oil,
you know,
obviously my father in law is older than me and so I get it,
but you know,
you don't have to indirectly tell me about it,
man.
I wish I just would have listened to him.
You know?
It keeps you in the game way longer.
Way Better.
Anyway,
get on the Krill oil vice.
Yeah,
you've got to get them.
right.
How can you not really,
I said do it.
Yeah,
get on that.
Pardon the pun on it yet on that,
on it,
on [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko get 10% off of anything you get on there.
There's some good stuff on there by the way.
You can get addicted to the website itself because it's so interesting and
informative
if you like.
Um,
interesting and informative.
I didn't say it like this.
You didn't know.
I didn't pretty much again,
no comment.
Anyway,
there's some good stuff on there.
Um,
also Amazon,
click through.
What that does is it before you do your Amazon shopping,
go to the website Jocko,
podcast.com.
Click on the Amazon link.
There's a few of them.
They're on the front page.
You can find them.
Click on there before you do shopping.
Do your shopping as normal,
whether you're getting the book,
any book or anything else,
duct tape,
whatever.
Click through that link and it supports this podcast a little bit.
Um,
also subscribe iTunes,
Google play,
stitcher,
all these podcast platforms.
That's a good way to support leave a review if you're in the mood,
right?
I say affirmative.
Yeah,
approved.
Proved by Jocko reviews.
Um,
also on youtube we are putting excerpts I think now on a regular basis,
right?
Would you
give you like a out of 10,
like a 3.2?
I see that's better than zero c.
So boom,
subscribe to Youtube.
You'll get some excerpts along with the video version of this podcast.
If you're into looking at what Jocko looks like,
what Tom looks like or what I look like.
You can watch it on youtube.
There was a lot of controversy when we first put it on youtube because echo
doesn't look like what he sounds like apparently.
He sounds like a hipster 15 year old hipster hipster.
How something.
Yeah,
something more along little.
Did they know that?
I mean until they saw him,
Huh?
Then they figured out is it a 20 year old is
yeah,
I know man.
Dang.
But yeah,
you know,
if you're interested in that kind of stuff.
Um,
but the excerpts really are helpful because you can share them and people will
actually watch them.
Like my brother sends me this,
actually,
you know what I was about to say this like maybe two,
three times ago,
but I ended up,
for whatever reason that's like,
jade will send me a video and be like,
Hey,
watch this.
And then I'll be like,
Bro,
I'm not going to watch this video right now.
It's like five,
10 minutes long.
Actually it was like nine minutes,
something too much,
too much for me.
And He,
and the thing is nine minutes.
That's not that long.
But the point still stands.
You can't just send somebody episode 72 of this podcast that's almost three
hours long as say,
hey,
watch this real quick.
You can't do that.
Right.
It's not a quick one.
Exactly right.
Especially if it,
you know,
it,
especially if it's just that one little part of that they want I light.
Yeah.
Excerpts of usually highlights himself and just include my,
you know,
echo with another amazing point.
Yeah.
Well yeah man,
you know,
so yeah,
the all that's on youtube.
I even put them in little play lists too.
So you know,
some people that are like,
Hey,
I like this point and then I'll lead you to the next point.
And you know,
you can kind of keep it going.
Um,
but yeah.
That's cool.
I think it's cool.
Anyway,
also,
jock has a store,
it's called Jocko store Jocko store.com and look for the,
for this website.
Really it's a website with the store.
And I put those wallpapers back on there or your phone thing is,
I didn't technically,
I didn't take them off is when we switched platforms,
they just failed to translate.
So it was the platform's fault,
not yours.
No extreme.
This ownership on that one.
And you know,
I blame tech on that CT over there.
Dig It.
Oh,
we're going to get to that.
Yeah.
That's on the,
on the [inaudible] dot com.
Yeah,
you can get the Jocko white tea on there through there.
Um,
if you like t shirts,
those are on their
discipline equals freedom.
The reason I think that that's a good shirt might be opinion is because of
course the layers.
I get it.
But it is one of those simple little things like it's not,
and it's not like too extreme either.
It's not like
echo.
When we designed this shirt,
echo wanted to put a flying tank with dragon fire coming out of its mouth and a
scarf and a skull.
Yeah.
He's gonna put it all over the whole face,
all over.
See.
And I'd be like too much.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
So,
or you know,
like a saying like all eat your kids for breakfast.
If you mess with me and are those time kinds of crazy sayings that will only hit
maybe like one out of 100 times.
You know,
when someone reads it,
it's not that,
gosh,
you not with any of them laugh.
I don't think so.
But this is equals equals.
It's,
it's for lack of a better term,
understated yet powerful.
That's my opinion.
Anyway.
Other shorts down there,
um,
you know,
various,
uh,
messages and with those messages come layers.
And what that means is you can look at it and be like,
okay,
that's a cool shirt,
but there's more to it.
So if you listen to this podcast or listening to Jackie,
you'll be like,
oh,
I get it.
Right.
I mean,
yeah,
okay.
There's more than just what's on the surface.
There's another lane.
Yes,
exactly right.
You listen,
you know,
um,
some rash guards on their new rash guards going to come out in
less than one week.
Also,
good way to support this podcast.
Very good way to support yourself in your journey
journey.
Or we do.
Do people still use the word journey?
Your word man,
go with it.
I never feel comfortable using the word journey.
It says you weren't going anywhere.
I don't,
it goes get out of the actual journey.
But you know,
it's one of those things that you kind of hear people saying.
It kind of sounds epic,
but then when you say it,
it sounds real stupid.
I felt like the word journey is kind of like,
oh,
anyway.
Yeah.
All right.
If you're on your journey to what?
Get up early,
be more disciplined,
get a better diet.
Just get your health together.
Get your whole thing together.
This is what will help you there.
Okay,
so on this journey,
it's not going to be,
you're not going to be hitting every day like killing every day.
You're going to have some days going to be harder than others.
So if you're having trouble,
for example,
waking up early one day is what you're going to do.
You're going to search psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink on iTunes or Amazon music.
Okay.
So it's this album with tracks and you put it on your phone,
whatever you listen to the track that's going to help you get out of bed.
That one's called wake up.
What's it called?
Wake up.
Get after,
wake up and get after it.
Boom.
So instead of,
uh,
instead of hitting the snooze,
you hit or put it as your ringtone,
clear it with your wife or whoever you sleep with,
but put it as your ringtone.
It's Jockos voice.
He'll tell you why you should wake up and get after it.
And you,
that's convincing.
It is.
You did.
So I,
I mean we,
there was like one year we've had an,
I don't sit in this 100% success rate.
There's one guy,
because there's actually three jacks to wake up the first one to wake up the
second tech.
What did you just do?
You didn't get out of bed.
There's one guy out of a lot of people that have,
has made it to the second track.
Everyone else's first track word.
Yeah.
So you can't,
you can't not get up.
And again,
that's a rare case.
You know that guy,
he probably had a really hard night the night before looking into or looking
forward to really,
really hard day.
And that's why he was considering training wheels,
right?
Yeah.
And the whales,
it a spa.
I like spot.
Yeah,
it's better.
Yeah.
Training wheels kind of seems like without it you fall down.
You know,
this is just for,
you know,
if I'm trying to get that Max on bench,
this is the how.
This is a big goal I've got now.
I want to wake up for one year,
I'm going to wake up early or something like this.
It's like if I have a huge goal with the bench all I'm going to get it,
I'll probably get it.
But in the small case that let's say I'm not strong enough today,
I didn't get enough sleep or whatever,
I got a spot there.
Boom.
Yeah.
Then I'll get it.
Same thing,
same exact thing.
So yeah,
there it is.
Psychological warfare and this goes for,
for waking up early skipping workouts.
That's a big one in my opinion,
skipping workouts.
But that's just my experience.
And somebody asked me what was it?
What?
What do you say to yourself when you get tired and you want to quit?
You don't want to do anything anymore?
And I said,
I don't say anything to myself.
I just keep doing it.
Next question.
See what that is.
That's that menu set.
You know,
if you're on auto,
you're like,
what am I feel like?
Do we know if you're like not doing,
if I feel like I want to quit,
you just going to kind of sort of quick,
automatically no.
Namaste.
Take control.
Yup.
Exactly right.
So yeah,
boom.
There's a good psychological warfare.
Jocko Willink.
It's good for waking up early.
If you have a day that you don't want to wake up or you're going to slip on your
diet,
let's face it,
we come home,
we're hungry.
Nothing's in the house except for some donuts.
Oh,
snap.
The chance of you eating the donuts goes up a little bit.
Let's just face it.
Actually a lot supporting.
Exactly right.
That first.
I shouldn't have done it in your house.
But if you do in the event of you having done this,
yes,
listen to psychological warfare,
sugarcoated lies,
that's the name,
snack time and,
and the psychological warfare album number two is being slowly prepared at this
point.
It's,
it's Bruce,
people were asking me for specific tracks,
little areas of weakness in life,
you know a also Jocko white tea and you can get it on amazon.com after you click
through,
if you don't want to deadlift in excess of 8,000 pounds,
don't get it.
Get a different kind of tea if you want to deadlift 8,000 pounds guaranteed.
Good Jocko white tea.
Cause that's what it does.
It does taste good though in all seriousness.
And I got to get some of that.
I think we have any here we give you some age limit on that or what?
No,
no,
we are,
I do have to give you a heads up.
There is,
we haven't done it yet,
but we're gonna have to put some kind of a fertility warning on there as well
because apparently several drinkers have impregnated their wives shortly after
drinking Jocko white tea from unplanned.
Just gotta be careful is that w which is discipline equals freedom on the other
side or sort of
that,
you know what I mean?
Got gotta.
Yes,
exactly.
He need do you need to heat that with your loved one?
Uh,
way the war your kid gets when it's available now,
now
order it.
Amazon's going to start pre shifting it in in a day or two,
so get ahead of the rush.
Get it while you can because otherwise it's you're not going to get it and all
the other kids are going to be destroying your dreams with their strength and
power.
You can also preordered discipline equals freedom field manual that comes out in
October.
Of course,
extreme ownership.
You get that one if you want to lead and when you can get a copy of that for you
and your team.
Also while you're on Amazon,
you can get this book right here that we reviewed today,
brothers forever.
It's
read it,
get it,
read it.
You know,
written by Britain,
by the kernel here and again,
we went over a fraction of it today.
There's so many lessons learned in it.
Pick it up.
If you need leadership training beyond books,
you can contact echelon,
front leadership and management consultants,
applying combat leadership principles to business and life.
Email info@echelonfront.com.
Also the muster coming up,
round the corner,
Marriott,
Grand Marquis,
New York City,
May 4th and fifth leadership strategy,
tactics and winning.
Go to extreme ownership.com and sign up for that.
You can also sign up for the one that we're having in Texas,
by the way,
did you get that's available now we're in Texas,
Austin,
Texas over there yelling and academies there.
We will be having little sessions,
a session,
at least there.
It's been discussed with the folks at on it.
We're also hanging around on the interwebs and by the way,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Defac Book Echo is adequate.
Charles.
I am at Jocko Willink and for the Travis Manion foundation on Facebook and
Instagram,
you can search Travis when Travis Manion foundation on Twitter.
It's at t m foundation at t m foundation.
If you want to check out the Travis Manion foundation and on the interweb
itself,
it's Travis mannion.org
echo.
You got anything else?
We'll wait.
Travis wrestle that.
He's one 84 and navy.
So what did he walk around at like two 15?
You know the guys get better.
Wrestlers cut weight,
cutting a lot of weight there.
He's probably bad to 10 to 15.
He's big guy.
That's still a lot of weight.
That's a horse right there.
The big guys at one 84 college wrestler.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
All out.
Battle like injuries.
Yeah.
Tough,
tough.
Warn us.
Seems like the most,
um,
I don't want to say dynamic,
but the most like,
you know how you'd get heavyweights?
Huge power,
but they start to slow down.
Lightweight.
They're flying around super technical,
but they don't have that,
you know what I mean?
That part of then the one 80 fours.
The middle weights are tough.
They're really tough.
Yeah,
they got,
yeah,
they got both battles,
some bs in there.
Respect.
Thank you.
Echo.
Do you have any,
uh,
any,
any closing?
Closing comments?
Yeah.
Well I just,
um,
I want to thank you guys.
Thanks Jocko and echo for having me here and giving me the opportunity to talk
about the story a little bit and thanks for what you guys do to,
to talk about leadership and the lessons that you've learned Jocko and in the
navy seals and sharing that with others and bring in new insights about our men
and women in uniform.
I mean,
you hear so much these days about the troubles that our service members have,
you know,
whether they're missing a limb,
they don't have a job,
they've got PTSD.
But you know,
we,
we also should be talking about is what an inspiration they are.
The guys who put on the uniform,
the men and women have put on the uniform are an inspiration for this country.
And,
and thanks for what you're doing to get the word out there.
Thanks for giving me the opportunity to talk about this book,
but more broadly the story of our men and women in uniform and how they live
every day.
With that,
if not me,
then who motto.
Thanks
absolute honor,
sir.
And you know,
sort of one more thing before we close out.
I know you,
you,
you were talking about a letter that you had that kind of talked about some of
the leadership principles that
we really learn in the military and really make military leaders excel.
And it's a letter that you got from one of the marines that,
that work for your son.
Did
Christine that I'd do,
you know,
here I am coming out to talk to you and I've had the book published for a couple
of years now,
but I just,
I just got this letter.
Okay.
Uh,
through coach Garrett,
you talked about coach Sheraton and now this,
this marine that was with my son,
served with my son,
hooked up with coach,
showered at one of the wrestling events and said,
hey,
you know,
colonel man,
you'd give him this letter.
Yeah.
And,
um,
you know,
here he is checking in uh,
after 10 years and he says,
um,
okay,
things he'd like to share with me.
A couple of things,
things that are not well known by people other than those in my myself that
serve with Travis and Fallujah,
those memories or things I'm able to hold on to,
but I've been wanting to share with his family as well.
I apologize for such a long silence.
It seems to be the best opportunity for me to share them with you by passing
along this letter
and he actually passed along the bracelet.
He had Travis's name on a bracelet he'd worn for the past 10 years,
especially as he says with 10 year anniversary coming up.
He talked about your,
the backstory is from Columbus,
Ohio.
He joined Lima company then meant Travis and the rest of the marines in January,
2007 as they rotated into work with the Iraqi army counterparts
at the time,
I hit my two year mark in the core,
but in not yet have an opportunity to work with a true leader with so many with
so few marines assigned to the mid team,
Travis was my team leader.
Travis was a true leader and someone that was easy for me to look up to and
respect.
He had the perfect balance of caring for his marines without babying them.
Discipline,
without being too harsh,
being laid back.
We're not involved in missions while standing.
We'll still leading from the front and once it got time to get the work done and
we talked about that
as I progress through my military career,
Travis was the leader that I strive to be.
Your son said the example of how a leader should be.
I read the book and enjoyed learning more about him as a man,
not just a marine.
I also enjoyed getting to know Brendan and they're incredibly,
where our friendship,
it made it easy for me to connect how he was as a person back home and how he
was raised.
So he said I wanted to share two stories,
so I hit the highlights of this.
But first story
he found kind of humorous and you've talked about Travis having a sense of
humor.
So here you go.
It's February.
Uh,
there were out the patrol turn out to be uneventful for the most part until they
started returned to the outpost.
As they return,
they were returning an IED.
It was initiated.
Is She initiated?
An ambush started.
Thankfully the ID IED did not detonate the artillery shell.
It was attached to,
but the only,
but only the blasting cap and knows of the shell blue.
This injured his soldier
and another Iraqi soldier was shot while rushing to the aid.
Both were non life threatening.
Once the ambush start,
I began writing radioing back to request Qfr.
Although Travis was not on the patrol,
he managed to find a way to get on the Qfr two QRF team as a short and Bush
subsided.
The QRF showed up.
Travis's presence,
calm.
Any nerves that I had the injured Iraqi had already taken back to receive
treatment.
What I remember most about the situation was that tribes always about Travis.
That brings a smile on my face.
I was standing on the north side of the road and Travis was on the south.
I remember he began to cross the road and a job just as an Iraqi soldier let out
of burst from is eight k to the east to stop a vehicle from approaching.
As soon as the burst went off,
Travis tripped across the road doing a barrel roll and coming back to his feet
with his helmet,
push back on his head.
As soon as he reached me on the north side of the road,
he said,
is everybody okay over here?
I've replied,
yes sir.
Everyone is okay.
Are you okay,
sir?
To which he responded.
Yeah,
but somebody should get that pothole fixed
and a near death experience for me.
This uh,
laughter as my leader had been startled by an Iraqi army.
One he shot causing the form bowel roll in the middle of Iraqi street.
So having that sense of humor,
right,
being able to laugh at yourself.
And then the other story shared is,
is is about this guy's birthday.
My second story,
Travis is more sentimental.
My birthday is April 3rd and I'm turning 21 that night.
We all slayed it,
were slated for overnight observation,
searching for possible ids,
but I've been pulled from the mission to remain behind.
I thought nothing of it and went to bed on the second ready to be on the cute
QRF in case anything were to happen at midnight.
I was woken up and told I needed to go to the coc because they were requesting
me over the radio.
I shook the cobwebs from my head and walk to the COC.
After calling to the patrol on the radio,
I was greeted with Travis Travis's voice in a whisper simply to wish me happy
birthday.
Throughout the madness of patrolling,
staying awake all night and searching for Ids.
He had kept me in mind.
And as soon as the day transition from the second to the third,
he called over the radio to wish me happy birthday.
A week later I left Iraq,
the Mitt team and Travis,
I will never forget that and I'll never forget him.
Yeah.
So you know,
I just received this the other day and you know,
I still hear from guys that he served with and just little things that,
you know,
caring about your people having a good sense of humor,
leadership traits that we can all
use,
no doubt about it.
Crazy held these themes.
They,
they,
they're coming,
you hear him everywhere.
As far as good leaders,
you know,
like all the good leaders,
they have these themes that,
that dichotomy,
like you gotta be strict,
but you can't be like a slave driver.
You know?
It's that balancing act.
I guess that's why there's just a few leaders because it's so hard to do.
You know?
It's like some people think,
oh,
I'm just going to go,
I'm an extreme guy.
You know,
I'm going to go extreme,
but it's not like that.
Even a guy with an extreme personality like Travis who can push himself that
hard to be a national level,
understands
leadership to a point where he knows what it means to call back to base while
you're out on patrol and wish her happy birthday to one of your men.
Yeah.
It's just awesome.
It's a good way to put it to echo.
It's a,
it's a balancing act,
you know,
for,
for everyone to sort of figure it out and you know,
just not one,
one situation for everyone.
Yeah.
Well,
sir,
thanks again for,
for coming on the show and in sharing this story.
Thank you for your service in the Marine Corps in,
of course.
Thank you for raising such an incredible man and marine and hero and so on.
And
once again,
we see
another,
another table,
another legend of bravery and of sacrifice
from these two oh,
ROIC leaders.
But I still want to remind everyone as always,
that these are not
imagined legends or myths.
Then these aren't
symbolic stories that were made up
to reinforce some ancient parable.
These are the wives of men.
Oh Man,
who stepped up and step forward and gave everything
for us.
And in that sacrifice,
and we see the unmeasurable suffering of the families rock with pain and yet
filled with pride.
Okay.
To No.
Yeah.
And to have absorbed the light and the love that these men emanated in life.
A light that will not fade
and will not grow old like the flesh
of light that will guide us all
down the righteous path toward the good,
regardless of the cost
for them.
We hold our heads higher
and do our best to make the world a better place
like they did.
We will do our utmost to emulate Brendan Looney.
We will be strong.
We will be accountable.
We will not complain.
Yeah.
And in the most trying of times,
we will ask ourselves a simple question.
Same One.
The Travis Mannion asked when he faced
the darkness of the world,
if not me,
than who.
So until next time,
this is Colonel Thomas Mannion good deco and Jocko
out.